[Applause]
but we're back
[Applause]
i don't think people got the jokes that
you were going for dan
and the intro sketch we did for our off
the rails last time because you were
going for the whole banished ethan with
the scar yeah
it was like a solid snake reference yeah
or approximately yeah yeah
punished ethan punished ethan yeah
i was punished
that's the name of your boss fight when
you're in that mode
okay that's what appears above the
health bar at the bottom punished ethan
okay wow
so guys welcome to after dark we got a
heck of a show
thank you
thank you
welcome to the show we got a great one
here today folks sponsored by mint
mobile upstart and crackin
how are you today elo how you feeling
i'm good
good
dude that sweater is sick thank you
thank you
when did it come out though
um i don't know at the end of the year
you want to show it off
um yeah
so sick
so sick man thank you thank you so uh
how's everybody doing today uh this you
know how's everyone feeling how was you
guys time off you guys take a little bit
of a time of like a week off like was it
did anything interesting happen during
our uh banishment exile
um
abe had a little adventure but um oh my
god there's one person that i know we
need to check in
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
gabe we missed you last week what what
what's up man what were you up to last
week what are you up to today
yeah we're
we're trying to drop the merch out
oh let me see that let me see that let
me get a good look at that is that you
shirtless
what you doing there you're eating fried
chicken
we're in beverly hills okay
fried chicken wednesday
[Applause]
where can we buy those i want some of
those shirts
we're standing there we're searching
everything's right through and stuff
all right cool man i want some of those
fried chicken shirts and i want them
signed by you can we set that up
okay zach you make that happen i want
everybody signed edition edition you got
it thanks buddy
yeah wait up to last week when you
didn't need me
oh we got suspended on youtube
yeah some dude named keemstar snitched
on us to youtube oh my god
yeah yeah it was bad but thank you for
your sympathy i really appreciate it
bye
baby it's friday
is this school tomorrow
no school tomorrow is it work
is there work tomorrow
hell no
oh no [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he said he's about to hit a million on
tick tock are you serious
gabe what gabe is going to hit a million
have you heard from white claw yet
yeah not yet oh man we got to reach out
we got to make that happen that's some
[ __ ]
we'll just we'll just do something else
yeah you guys
you should become budweiser gabe or
something if they don't capitulate
all right baby
take care gabe we'll see you next week
okay thanks for calling
come on baby it's friday it's friday
baby [ __ ] yeah baby [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
baby
[Laughter]
we missed him you know what's funny on
last friday when we missed the show
[Applause]
i was actually thinking about gabe i
always do it's like is he trying to call
now and just knowing yeah did anyone
tell me that the show was cancelled
was he just trying to call in
that zach's department
did you tell gabe that the show was
cancelled
yes i did
that sorry there was a weird noise yeah
we had
a channel open yeah
um
i'm tired man i'm not feeling i got to
say i'm still vegan roundup you clap
please clap still vegan
[Applause]
and uh i've been having like
stomach issues bro
but i don't know what because you're not
eating dairy or cheese like what could
mess up my stomach so bad that's what's
been confusing me
spicy yes it's i have been eating
i used to be so good with spice but now
it's like i have a little spicy and it's
like i'm destroyed for the whole week is
that really what it is yeah definitely
burning in that butthole
that's crazy man
i'm tired too theodore got me good last
night boy but okay
teddy got crane
teddy got the crime
listen there's a new windy meme you want
to see it yep
yup she's amazing
here
she never stops
he's like the meme fountain of youth i
mean uh or the meme eternal flame maybe
just always giving always shining for
the rest of us
nice full audience
they're packed in there man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you all for being here
dude
she's so funny she doesn't even have to
like
speak to be funny
to all of them no
that a woman oh wait
okay we missed the setup
she said i just want you all to know
slashed in the face
on 20th street right here in chelsea
just saying
that she was like no someone oh someone
yeah just a nice warm-up y'all feeling
safe you'll see you feel comfortable
[ __ ] you back outside
[Applause]
thank you all for being here
out of town you should know
that a woman was slashed in the face
on 20th street right here in chelsea
just saying
nice
audience
she's so wild
she's so wild
just saying
yeah oh one thing that did go down
during our exile was that we had this
whole drama where a.b
thought he saw james charles
and he was running him down and we were
all like dude you better go take a just
take a photo with him you know
that would be great and he's like i'm
going in he was you're kind of you're
kind of
beating around the bush with us if i can
be honest i felt like you weren't
committing to it i i didn't i didn't
want to walk up to him yeah i know i'll
be honest you were scared of james
charles you're not scared of him but
i don't know i understand
it's just weird as much as you think
like i'm a sim for all celebrities or
whatever and i
i just find it weird just walking up to
people
oh stop it you've walked up to so many
celebrities no i've taken sniper photos
but now i've never walked up
didn't you take a photo with someone
like really incriminating who was it oh
god rj might right wait who's that
five years ago actually today oddly
enough
i took a picture with dirty dog that is
isn't that amazing he has a selfie with
dirty dom
five years ago today okay you remember
the day
yeah why do you know that snapchat
it comes up in snapchat it shows your
memories
so were you nervous to ask dirty dom for
a photo
i know but he actually and you we've
already talked about this and you said
you didn't believe it but he actually
said something to me first
he said something about my genes right
you told us that story
and we didn't believe you yeah right
dirty dogs just walking around come here
nice jeans
he was on hollywood boulevard all by
himself and he just broke
stop the crap
i'm not like he's like oh are you a b no
he just like he was like staring down oh
sorry man he goes i was just looking at
your jeans i think i have those same
genes
do you think he was making a pass on you
maybe
when i told the story to lena because
lena was there like when i immediately
like after it happened so she didn't see
it happen
she saw me like walking away from him
but she thought oh nobody corroborated
yeah she thought he was i didn't think
he was
it sounds like he may have been he'll
cancel my life or whatever
can you pull let's see the photo i want
to see the [ __ ] so at the time you took
the pic this is good because it leads
into the james charles store
so at the time you took this photo with
dirty dom you were you were probably a
fan of the vlog squad
yes
that was around which is i mean that no
shade on you i mean people didn't know
about all this stuff back then i missed
the mark with that one
this is around the like the end of me
watching them like i didn't keep up
after that just because of yeah work and
it was like it was like may of this year
maybe this year yeah
any other photos with celebs that happen
to compliment your pants uh casually on
the street
not that i could think of you saw oj the
other day right
uh funny zach
all right well while you're working on
that so so abe starts sending us photos
from the mall he goes oh my god james
charles is here
and we're like dude go freaking take a
photo with him and you saw he thought he
was with security guards and stuff
yes yeah
he was with two big dudes
and i assumed
i'm sorry go ahead you could tell the
story oh you were there yes i thought
they were security guards so this is the
photo we got we're like bro that's
literally
we're like what the hell
listen when he walked out of the store
when i first saw him the look he gave me
was like the look of death like i've
never seen anyone
have that look you think he recognized
you the only reason i thought he might
recognize me just because of content cop
because i feel like that was the first
time a big channel sort of core sorry
contact court like the first time a big
channel
and so
uh
yeah he might have seen me from that
yeah but when you saw that photo we're
like oh dude and then we started all
sending photos like a picture of
shredder like oh my god i just ran into
oj
this oh you have those things yeah let's
look we had a whole great little thing
going on but you sent this photo
which did i mean this one does look
more like him really but it seems like
his dome is still big yeah
also he's not that glammed out you know
he i feel like he's being like uh some
kind of crazy outfit his face was
definitely
glammed out it looked he like from the
face he looked just like james i can't
believe you i can't believe you wouldn't
just go take a photo of him though at
least get a better photo than this jeez
i should have listened and i feel like i
didn't want to get sister slept
this is right i think that it's him
i'm sorry do you still think that was
him
i don't think it was him
because he was stalking him in the mall
for like a good 15 minutes and then when
we realized it wasn't even him they all
were putting pressure on me they're like
you're blowing it okay we were all
saying no balls we were all yelling out
so go ahead dan so this one uh this is
like right afterwards ian was like dude
i just passed lance armstrong on the
side of the road
yeah so there's that one
uh let's see what else we got here
that's so funny
here's one that uh cam sent it was like
obama to be out there he was in the
white house with obama yeah that is uh
obama so
here's uh
what who did you say that shredder was i
don't remember
[Laughter]
yeah i just took a picture of shredder
on the couch that was just like all this
[ __ ]
you said it was like david dobrik or
something you're like oh yeah larry
david i just ran into david dobrik oh my
god and then i was like oh wait no
that's just straight oh it's a shredder
sorry
but you know what i do applaud uab for
for getting out there and trying thank
you
yeah lena took a video of it uh it's not
that exciting but worse than me is lena
got nervous after i walked in and cut
the video like immediately after walking
in it's so funny you guys were nervous
of nobody yeah
what is this one dan oh remember when
abe first got here he told us that he
ran into uh walt jr at uh
at the store at target
yeah there's actually documentary
evidence
[Laughter]
and i didn't want to
bother him yeah so yeah that's good wait
is that guy actually um what's the the
cerebral palsy yeah yeah but it does
yeah you can't really that might be in
poor taste to pretend to have that these
days i don't know all right
i believe there's some like it's
something i think maybe has i don't know
i want to talk about it actually i don't
think it's exactly the same as the show
i'll just say that i like the twilight
movies
yeah
so that was fun
good times
good times great oldies
so you know oh we got more memes
you know this is what you asked for
there's just oh we got the photo no way
here we got the photo of a b and dirty
dom
oh no
you gotta appreciate a guy who names
himself dirty dom and lives up to it
just a couple of cool dudes what was
that like for you
that is such a weird story i do think
you if if the story is true for you
telling us it's true
right
then yes he was kind of trying to hit on
you i ca it sounds like like he was
making a pat if he's just like oh sorry
i was just staring at your jeans like
what the [ __ ] he was yeah like oddly
looking down
and i thought your dick out
no
well your dick wasn't didn't have an
imprint your dick wasn't out it wasn't
outside your dreams
now well like it's just two dudes
passing each other on the street i would
never ever just stop and look at a
dude's jeans i mean that's well okay
big ass eyes so it's possible like
i did like a look at him and like my
eyes were like wide and trying to see
who he is and then he thought i was
staring at him staring at me
i was just looking at you i like those
jeans
no
that's not what happened
i think you could [ __ ] dog i think you
have an opportunity here maybe
or did at least how long ago was this
five years five years ago
dude we should do an update on dirty dom
because he's been up to some such weird
[ __ ] actually let's pull up his tick
tock he keeps pretending like he's
hanging out with david
pretending it's so
bizarre
no it's it's seriously like mentally it
like
here let's see dirty dom on tick tock it
dude i i whenever i pull this [ __ ] up i
just i can't believe what i'm seeing
um
oh my god dirty don bought a lambo
here let's just pull some off that
during tom's lambo yo yo dirty tom
turning down i'm dirty dom i made it and
y'all hate it listen it's lonely at the
top man when i decided to get serious
about my life goals i lost a lot of my
friends but that's why my lambo got it
that's why you lost friends
got [ __ ] 30 seats
[Music]
it's not that hard to believe this guy
was being weird no i i i didn't have any
trouble believing yeah
yeah he just bought a 250 000 lambo
thank you i'm [ __ ] i'm rich hit the
lambo the [ __ ] the prayer request i just
wanted to let you know that what the
hell what the [ __ ]
this one has 10 million i wonder why you
look at the thumbnail
i was just wondering
is that it oh he did one of these dumb
he's not even in it that's why people
didn't realize they were liking his
video
i'm trying to find one where he pretends
to be with david i sent it in the
discord
oh here it is oh my god dirty dom and
david dobrik reunited
this is from july so this is well after
right yeah
and it's old footage
oh it's old food yeah it's old footage
and then he wrote
he also wrote in the description ready
for this
shouldn't he be in jail already
about himself dude
what is that what is going on here
is that the one you sent me or was there
another one
yeah
can you imagine what
it's really weird it's really weird
i guess this is better than getting a
regular job i don't know
clickbaiting that you're a predator and
stuff
he's like anything to be other than
going back to work here's another one
look at this
bro
oh my god david and dom are back
david and dom are back
[Music]
can you believe how disturbing this is
in the midst of what
so weird
what is he trying to do i don't get it
here they threw dirt on our names they
tried to end us try again
that's what he wrote
i feel like david could probably sue him
for this
[Laughter]
he went and got an extra that looked
like david gang for life
wait that's what you think this is yeah
because it's just someone with hair oh i
just assumed it was old footage again no
he got an extra that looked like david
gang for life bro
or it's just a friend that looks like
david yeah he but you could tell he
they're acting oh my god yeah that's
that's next level right yes
dirt game for life baby
uh is just weird
i think if i'm not mistaken at one point
when they were still friends he did a
prank where he hired a look-alike to
kiss him so that the reporters would
have the photo and then he came out the
video after saying it was it wasn't
really david
dude there's so many of them here's
another one oh my god david and dom
somebody said this is like the guru on
the ellen show oh [ __ ]
that's a good observation
we did the whole video remember the guru
the guru
[Laughter]
that is still one of the [ __ ] wildest
things that has ever happened
like that that's like next level i
actually i don't know if you guys
remember but or if maybe you weren't
watching then yeah there was this uh
east european guru who was obsessed with
going on the ellen show
and he hired a look-alike and built this
whole set
created the entire ellen set and then he
was also doing things where he was like
hacking the tick remember the plane
tickets to sit next to celebrities yes
that guy was wild i wonder if i should
show that
i always wonder if we should re-watch it
because it's so can you pull it up find
the original yeah i mean a lot of people
here probably haven't seen it because
it's so old
that video just it keeps getting worse
and worse too as you keep watching dude
that was one of our best videos it
really story was just so unbelievable
and eli your thumbnail on this was
amazing
by the way let's keep watching because
there's like way more of this
oh my god david don filming again
david that's the same look again that he
hired
the gang's back
like the most obviously fake laughter
and down filming again so his response
to being accused of being a predator was
to hire a david dobrik look-alike yeah
and make a whole series of david
what are the comments saying like
i can't look i can't read the comments
because i'm not logged in
oh the tick tock comments yeah yeah
but
is he trying to like get david the [ __ ]
as out of revenge or
is he just trying to get views it's hard
i mean did david even
do anything like he didn't throw him
under the bus
as far as he kind of dropped them it was
after dom made the video first he made a
video first about david and then david
did right after oh yeah dom made a video
like exposing david oh preempting right
he was trying yeah
dude that guy's wild bro
holy [ __ ] here's another one oh my god
david and dom are back no way look at
this
man he got good mileage out of this
look-alike at least
a whole day of fun pretending to have
his friend back
this is so weird it's so weird
oh yeah well just read a few
i don't care just curious what's the
what's the reaction okay the top comment
is on this video it's actually david
this time of the one of actually him and
david uh bro you're really trying to
keep your head above water you almost
turned everything you almost ruined
everything he worked for he don't feel
you
dude is literally making fun of the
situation yeah how desperate can one man
be
yeah
at least yeah people are dunking around
here's another one
me showing up to david's house after he
kicked me out of the vlog squad
accurate actually
at least that one's on it yeah
wow
man this guy fell from grace what a mess
what a mess of a human
i smashed riley reed should i click this
i have a feeling it's gonna be a
nightmare
a little okay wait don't show it let me
i want to preview it don't show it again
yeah he's off of it
okay
wait
okay
i'm out it's not even worth it
yeah
that's weird [ __ ] man that's some of the
weirdest things i've seen on the
internet somebody in the chat said that
they watched the fake l h3 video like
once every couple months they're from
poland and they know about that guy
right apparently they're sh yeah right
apparently they're a known personality
yes this guy is relatively famous in
poland as i recall what is he up to
today and um here this was our video
about it
polish guru fake being on the ellen show
this is the crew [ __ ] believe this
wait so we
in the description yeah let's see
let's see or not source video baby oh
look at that attribution oh it's still
up
one point two million
and ninety thousand dislikes oh yeah
lucas jacobiac
so this is 21 minutes i'm just gonna
paraphrase it for you
his dream is to be a guest on the ellen
show by the way that dream will never
happen
rest in peace ellen
joe not ellen but alan shell
wait what oh
she's gone
so his whole thing was visualization is
the most powerful motivational tool if
he could just visualize it happening it
would happen yeah and he took it out a
little too literal he said this dude is
the king of shifting that's true he
shifted he shifted he shifted into the
balance studio
all right
so anyway if you know ellen oh so so the
weird and the weirdest thing is he
thinks that this video which is
basically enough grounds for her to get
a restraining order
he says if you know alan publish this
link on her fan page post it share it
forward it to anyone so we can reach out
um
somebody in the chat says that he was
famous but this video pretty much ended
their career oh
yeah
just saying
just saying
yeah it's so
yeah that's the weird part is he thinks
by making this video
allen's gonna bring him on but here it
is
so here he pretends to get a uh
and now everyone's talking about it
maybe not really so this is the fake
so he builds this whole fake set in
poland
and simulates a whole ellen experience
so here it is my next guest is
we will see each other for the first
time
maybe not really he says the best way to
accomplish dreams is to visualize them
and he's like surprisingly so good to
the next level
to be a guest on my show
such a dollar store ellen
this [ __ ] kills me dude this is so crazy
yeah it's one of the best videos i think
we've ever watched
but i love how she goes this isn't the
first time i've seen him well i have
seen him in my bedroom at night watching
me sleep he says the best way to
accomplish dreams is to visualize them
and he did something more it is
visualization to the next level she was
dreaming to be a guest on my show watch
this
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah this is like a super high budget
tim and eric episode
so here he is
he can't believe it he's on the allen
show
he loves her
this is unreal you guys keep on the
ellen show i'm okay thank you
i'm great thanks oh my gosh
how should i pronounce your name
you can call me lucas but exactly sukash
okay i will stick to lucas so you are a
youtuber yeah but i'm also a
motivational speaker i heard you gave a
lecture for by the way in his like
fantasy
ellen is just like such a uh just doing
like a total puff piece for him
yeah 30 000 people at the stadium you
must be good at this
that's the reason why i'm here
you're not there
you're not there
what's
you're not there oh god
i wonder if ellen is seamless she must
have i'm sure yeah it was it was
it was wild yeah it was all over the
internet when it happened oh my god this
really is one of the funniest things
that anybody's just saying just saying
just saying he might be able to get on
wendy williams
that is that's true
[Laughter]
yo i just remember a story uh i was
listening to howard stern and there's
this caller who calls in called king of
all blacks and he was telling a story
about how he went to the wendy williams
show oh and he just met and when she got
up he went and smelled her chair and
they kicked him out
did you hear that
apparently he like has a fly
yeah she sniffed her chair real fast he
he uh
he does that with his wife when she
leaves for work so
yeah
i smell your chair yellow
don't tell me that i would smell your
chair that's how much i love you but i
haven't
thank you i appreciate that just saying
in the behind the scenes video i did at
the old office i actually think i did
smell your chair thank you you would
smell what the wait what did you say
and behind the scenes i did at the old
office you smelled my chair i think i
did wait you i thought you smelled like
i've ripped there
i smelled somebody's chair you smelled
my chair for a gag i smelled somebody's
chair but i don't remember which one
okay zach yeah smell yours you want to
come smell my chair right now i'd be
if you want me to i don't if you want to
maybe later
wait keep the show going you passed the
test
tonight after everybody's left you
passed the test
i want to smell fit we are meeting for
the second time although we don't know
each other at all so
you made reality work the way you wanted
how did you come up with this
oh i was dreaming about that for so many
years and i think this came up in my
head
this is the in his fantasy this is the
second time that he's going on the show
right
nobody knows what you just said um no i
think she i think okay
it's super meta she's saying
this it's it's super hot so this is the
first time right but because this is a
reenactment of alan this is the second
time yeah she's saying the first time
was when you pretended to me which is
this the second time which is this time
is the real
but it's also the first time
it's the best yeah
i mean you gotta you gotta
appreciate a man who goes after what
he's passionate about
thank you sam is this uh non-dairy
what's in it just creamer okay i'll just
hit it i'll just make it oh my god you
know what i'll be honest i had a tiny
bit of eggs oh my god
oh man it tastes like so rich [ __ ]
exposed dude no listen
when that when i began my vegan journey
people told me you're gonna slip up it's
gonna happen just stay on the journey
that's true for the most part i've been
vegan for like three weeks now right
neil or maybe more
i have no idea um i've only slipped up
like i had this morning half a burrito
it was vegetarian had eggs and i was
like fine
so this is the second slip up today yeah
well and then sam's like here's a coffee
it has some cream in it i was like i'm
not going to be that guy it's like
what am i going to take the cup like
splash it in her face you just got to go
with the flow a little bit you tried to
uh eat my chicken burrito too though
don't be a liar
don't [ __ ] lie on me
i'm just saying what happened it was a
breakfast burrito with eggs
you came over and you said are you gonna
eat that
[Music]
you're lying what no that happened when
what are you today or another day today
you dirty little liar you're like don't
lie on me bro there are witnesses i
could get a witness
i wasn't there for that
there was a breakfast burrito with eggs
in it
we got breakfast burritos what are you
talking about chicken how dare you yeah
actually there was no burritos with
chicken
what did i just eat
some burrito that's been laying around
the office for a week it was a breakfast
i was told it wasn't one of the
recommendations but we got breakfast
burritos bro oh wait that was mine from
last weekend
[Music]
you know what really did scare me though
is i did have leftover chipotle that i
had here and i was like no way he just
ate that because there's no chicken but
we okay and ian's been having like uh
those holes in the store right here
holes on life support
[Laughter]
do you want to talk about what you're
dealing with ian
i mean no not much to say but i'm never
going to chipotle ever again
like every time
someone gets sick from chipotle it's
crazy because it's like you know it's a
meme it's just rice and beans and like
why
i've never gotten sick from chipotle
really well you know what ian tells
never happened oh tell us about what you
ate because the story's pretty funny
actually
the music
uh well i i'm i've had a soft uh
distancing from chipotle i don't go
there but sam wanted to go the other day
and they messed up her order so they had
an extra bowl
[Music]
and the bowl was an abomination it was
really bad i actually have a photo of it
yeah it was in the chat right i'd love
to see it let me pull it up evidence
yeah now did you take this photo before
you got food poisoning or before because
i was disgusted by the look of it okay
yeah i remember that so you saw the bowl
and you're like this is horrific and
took a photo well this person whoever's
bull i accidentally got uh they ordered
extra steak
here
send that to dan so i can put oh
oh my goodness can you zoom in on that
what a night what a disaster that does
look like um extra steak extra corn
extra cheese holy god
i shouldn't have eaten it okay you know
what's the most disturbing thing about
that for some reason it's the extra corn
yeah that's weird and my my message was
like whoever ordered this
is a very uh untrustful or untrustworthy
person right bag of turrets flaming turd
bag
here's the best part
so ian beast modes it
saves it for the next day
and then eats the whole [ __ ] thing
the next day
oh over that will kill you is that right
ian pretty much that's what did it and
then when did it hit you
within uh
about four hours
the back half of it
it was light to begin with and then the
back half the the follow-up that was
what put it over was the kill shot yeah
right and i'm about three days in
thanks for coming to work i mean i know
that
yeah my uh
yeah just don't go in the bathroom today
no that's all right it's not that bad
but i'm in pain my stomach hurts
damn
i'm off it
never going ever again yeah do you think
he'll really be able to never go back i
feel like we've said that and we still
went back i agree
we said it looks like zach's turd
[Laughter]
it looks like i mean it must look just
like that coming out it's just looks
just put a brown hue on that and you're
pretty much
[Music]
in the front yard of just looking at it
i'm having that does make me sick
i feel like as long as i look at this
i'll never want to eat
the thing about chipotle it's addicting
in a weird sense like it's so weird yeah
they
they
do chipotle needs to do something
they can't keep going like this
i just i i keep getting away with it
they can't keep getting away with this
no i'm serious there's something needs
to happen to them yeah they need to
change
it's time to change to bro they stop
making everyone [ __ ]
we can't do this anymore
this relationship isn't working right
and we want it to work because we love
chipotle we grew up eating chipotle it
was revolutionary when that [ __ ] hit
grew up i didn't grow up eating
chocolate i was a teenager when it came
out but the first time i ate it i was
like can i come back here every day
it's like it's the same way yeah exactly
that's how i felt too i was in high
school the first time i had chipotle and
i was blown away
the guac huh they have been around
longer than i thought but you know it's
like it's like a game it's like you hit
the crack pipe once and you're like this
is awesome i'll do this every day but
fast forward a couple years it's ruining
your life you know i'm kind of curious
can we do like a like a poll who's had
diarrhea from chipotle and who hasn't oh
yeah i want to know the ratio yeah
because dan not having one and be honest
guys be honest but in my by my estimate
it's going to be like 90 plus who i've
had it's a guarantee you will get
diarrhea yeah
guarantee they need to put that in the
fine print they need to put a disclaimer
you will get diarrhea
yeah let's do a full you know
i think it's gonna be 90 plus but guys
be honest
be honest
just yes or no right
yes or no
has chipotle giving you diarrhea let's
figure it out now let's get to the
bottom of this
i don't remember who it was but someone
worked there or like a friend of someone
worked there
and they always said how they really um
they they care about the food and they
seems above the border you could see
them cooking everything right the
chopping the chicken
all right here we go pulls up i'm
spamming it in the chat it's pinned all
right have you had diarrhea
from chipotle
oh
this is crazy
mom well this is very little numbers
let's let it refresh we only have 200
votes in now but early exit polls are
suggesting a much closer margin yeah
than i would have guessed can you
refresh it
um
holy oh my god you guys that is very
surprising
dan can you put it on the screen
[Music]
i i can't believe what i'm seeing the 60
is saying no diarrhea
60
is saying no
i mean this is blowing my mind
you're acting as if you're surprised
that it's so low
i mean i feel like for any restaurant if
40 of your customers are getting
diarrhea that's not a great
physical ratio
i think this was an l for chipotle
i didn't think it would be 90.
i really did
i'm almost one out of every two people
yeah no this is not great this is not
great
if i get a chipotle burrito that'll ruin
my whole week call the health department
but also we just asked about diarrhea it
could
people may not consider what it gives
them diarrhea like you you all know that
chipotle yo you'll know what are you
referring to like doesn't
isn't diarrhea require more like liquidy
[ __ ]
would always complain that chipotle
would give him hard shits
oh so like he's constipated bro oh so
he's going the other way around
from chipotle yeah that's not happening
that's crazy
you want to do a poll on cooper no
i don't think so i think
and
it it's like you know it's a chipotle
[ __ ] because you you just feel it
there's a feeling to it yeah
yeah it is it's it's a rare breed but
you can feel kind of a diarrhea yes it
is
one that makes you a question going to a
proctologist
now on the flip side
the fact that 40 percent of people are
[ __ ]
and yet we all keep going back yes
they should put that in the commercial
like
you're [ __ ] your brains out but you
keep coming back
yeah that might be a selling point it's
a good point maybe they should sponsor
us and that would be our yeah approach
they sponsor david
he says he eats there every day
we gotta we gotta hire a private
detective to follow because i guarantee
you didn't eat that every day
every day
you know but they they paid these
influencers to be like this is my order
at chipotle mine would be
this
extra corn
extra chicken extra spicy salsa
dude that that's laxative right there
that's what you eat before you go in for
a colonoscopy sometimes i eat chipotle
and i wonder am i losing weight because
i'm not digesting any of this like i
genuinely wonder
if it's a good diet food because it just
makes me have diarrhea
anyway that's the allen i don't i don't
know if there is anything else to we
need to uh do our ad reads okay yes it
is the time the code of the sure thing
all right guys speaking of which thank
you to our beautiful sponsors for
supporting us chipotle
thank you to chipotle
yeah i mean let's be honest we're
probably driving people some people are
going to buy chipotle because i saw a
lot of people in the chat saying i
really want chipotle
just from like talking about it 100 and
there's part of me too there's like i
could eat you all day okay
like be honest i'm gonna have it for
dinner that's the problem
it's so weird there's something ain't
right with that food that's something
they're putting something yeah
in that
that ain't right
right equal life
correct i know the e coli is addictive
but i'm not a scientist
thank you to mint mobile
after years of fine print and getting
ripped off by big wireless providers if
we've learned anything it's that there's
always a catch so when i heard that mint
mobile offers premium wireless services
starting at just fifteen dollars a month
i thought what's the catch
but after speaking with them and using
their service it all made sense there
isn't one
mobile secret sauce is that they're the
first company to sell wireless service
online only by cutting out the retail
stores there's no crazy overhead costs
that get passed down to you in the form
of mysterious fees instead mint
just passes on the street beautiful
savings directly to you dan tell me
about your experience with mint
uh i was on one of the big carriers you
know the ones i won't say their names
here like voldemort but uh i was paying
nearly 100 a month i was able to get a
comparable plan from mint for a fraction
of the cost
and uh the service is just as good so
it's a win-win win
people looking for extra savings mobile
offers premium wireless for just 15 a
month all plants come with unlimited
talk and text high speed data delivered
on the nation's largest 5g network you
can use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan and keep your same phone
along with all of your existing contacts
and if you're not 100 satisfied mim
mobile has you covered with their
seven-day money-back guarantee so switch
on over to mint mobile and get premium
wireless services starting at just 15
a month to get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and get your
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
that's mintmobile.com
after dark cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks
a month
at minimum.com after dark thank you
thank you peace and love
those the links are all in the
description right then already they sure
are thank you good work appreciate you
up start it's time to start it up
up start
it's time to start it up
if you're carrying a credit card balance
month after month it can feel like
you're in a never-ending cycle of debt
but upstart can help you make that final
payment so you can get right ahead
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest at or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used up start to get
one fixed monthly payment upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and it's expanding access to affordable
credit unlike other med lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment to find you a smarter rate
for your loan with a five minute online
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans between one thousand and
fifty thousand dollars and you can
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
after dark that's upstart.com after dark
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you
loan amount will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information private your loan uh loan
application
start
dot com
slash after dark
thank you thank you
and finally
you know kraken exchange
owned by our good friend of the show
he was uh
he's the man
jesse powell the man
from kraken exchange
powell he's a great guy honestly we had
a whole conversation on the podcast
about crypto and this guy is one of a
kind
for the last 10 years kraken has been
one of the best platforms for trading
crypto online and now with the new
kraken app it's easier than ever to buy
and sell
over 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies on the go 24 7.
simply download the kraken app connect
your bank account and start investing
for as little as 10 dollarenos
just a minute is all it takes to get
started and with the new kraken app
you'll have your portfolio in your
pocket wherever you go
monitor your investments
track your winners and losers
keep tabs on your favorite projects or
view the most traded cryptocurrencies of
the day
it's got it all
it's got all the features you need with
none of the complexity it's the simpler
way to invest kraken
kraken.com
h3ad go to kraken.com h3 to start
investing if you're interested in crypto
please use kraken friends of the show we
love them kraken.com
h3ad thank you thank you
[Music]
all peace where were we
um we were over are we over the ellen
guy yeah yeah moving on from the island
go watch the h3
h3 productions
some requests for baby update sure
i
honestly don't have much to update i'm
still
dying to know the gender but i don't
know yet we should find that out soon
right yeah i hope so and
yeah i'm week 16 so i think they said
it's around 18 to 20 weeks when you find
out
okay so like two weeks so is it the size
of a avocado or the pit it's the size of
an avocado right now
wow that's quite a big discrepancy in
avocado sizes i want to say right seen
some monster avocados it says four to
five inch or three to four
ounce
i think it's a girl
it has to be
um what tells you that
just that we wanted to
gotcha it's different i can tell the
pregnancy is different it is different
um i do kind of think that it's a girl
too but we'll
see
you know what i want to do next is there
anything you want to add about that
uh no i overall i feel pretty okay i'm
like i'm fine just more tired
yeah you've been tired eli doesn't get
she doesn't get morning sickness yeah he
doesn't feel nauseous ever so
yeah so
um pretty much all the same except tired
i fell asleep earlier
is it possible that it makes me tired
you being pregnant
no
how do you know
you're making an assumption should we do
a big gender reveal party on the show
burn the building then
yeah we can
uh
we can put like color start a wildfire
yeah yeah yeah let's burn it down let's
bring it down
lena told me she suggested that to ela
i'm like to burn the building no to do a
gender reveal party i'm like do you not
watch the show
i mean it's a fun idea i think i don't
think there's anything wrong with gender
reveal parties i think they can be fun
and awesome just don't explode
pyrotechnics yeah exactly that's when
you
burn
yeah to the desert yeah
now is not the time for that
so um let's do this personality test i'm
actually really excited about unless
there's something oh so someone said
that if i go to a 3d ultrasound place
that's like not covered by the insurance
um they will tell you the gender now
already
yeah i've heard about those places
didn't your sister do it or someone we
know do it it was really cool
the the baby completely looks freaky
from what i remember when i saw my
sister do it it's totally just for fun
though it doesn't really have any real
value in right right
well it sounds like we're going to find
out soon regardless yeah
so
that's exciting i remember when we found
out theodore was a boy i was like i
wanted a boy so i was really excited
yeah but now i got like
i'm just i would like a girl just
because he's like such a boy he only
wants tractors
and like to leave bruises on me all day
just because he's like so
he's a boy
last night he's wanted to sleep with his
uh roller tractor
and his forklift yeah
he had a forklift and a roller that he
wanted to sleep with those last night
he's so funny he's obsessed with trucks
but flatbed truck is his favorite truck
flatbed which is like i mean not to
judge him he's a truck guy that's like
he's just a truck guy
no anytime i come to the house he's
very eager to let me know about whatever
truck he's currently in
[Laughter]
so um
you want to do this personality test
this is this is kind of exciting me yes
okay this i've been looking forward to
we did a personality test previously but
that was a narcissism test right yeah
that was the one recommended by dr drew
and
oh i wish i remember the other guy's
name because he was the guy who actually
came on and uh went over it with us
remember no i remember me right now he
was really a great guy yeah he was um
yeah and that was the dark triad it was
called right and uh
there was one other one and yeah that
was the one where we found out that uh
that zach is truly joking
yeah exactly
zack abe and trisha scored high on the
narcissist yes and uh you you were
right in the middle i remember oh i was
at the excuse me
or something i was in high i was high in
a one certain section which he found
weird because i wasn't in the rest of it
yeah i just remembered that ian was like
non-existent yeah
ian was the one that was like
transcendent he was the lowest score
they'd ever seen they said he was oh
people said doctor young thank you for
reminding me dr young shout out to dr
young he was great
yeah he was really nice he came on the
show it was really fun ian i still i
still am not 100 convinced that ian did
that honestly because how can you get a
game bro like you have you have no ego
you basically are heir you don't even
how is that possible you lied on that
tell me the truth i mean you've met me
man you know the vibes you know the vibe
right
well this one is a little bit more uh
pop science
i don't think that many psychologists
take this very seriously but there were
a lot of requests for it there was a big
reddit thread where somebody um
suggested that we all take it and try
and guess each other's uh
letters or whatever it's called the
myers-briggs test
let me let me describe what is the
mayor's briggs test now i'll say i took
this test
i was very thoughtful i i took a while
on it i tried to give the best possible
answer to everything and the result i
thought was super
accurate
when i got my result i also felt that it
was pretty accurate there you go so we
said the same thing yeah but yeah i
think it's just overall like positive
right well that's the thing it doesn't
really tell you that you're like you're
a piece of [ __ ] there's like there's no
like you're doomed yeah
forever alone or something good vibes
yeah
it could just be like astrology where we
all kind of have these
human traits but
i think it's a little astrology issue
yeah i was reading about it's maybe not
as uh what in peace and love to our
astrology fans in the fan base but i
think it's it has a little bit more
validity than that um but i was reading
just a wikipedia article about it in
their criticism section and most uh
psychologists say that it's not thorough
enough
that makes sense yeah i mean it was like
what 50 questions of like yeah exactly
zero to five something it's not to give
you any real deep insights but that said
it's it's just a fun thing so what i do
think it's useful in giving a um
a good like overview i think it's
actually interesting here i want to read
there's a lot of people already putting
what theirs are
so the mayor's briggs type indicator and
personal personality typology it's an
introspective self-report questionnaire
indicating different psychological
preferences on how people perceive the
world and make decisions
uh the test attempts to assign four
categories introversion or extroversion
sensing or intuition
thinking or feeling
judging or perceiving
one letter from each category is taken
to produce a four letter test results
such as infj or enfp
knowledge
knowledge and the one that we took
actually threw another letter in there i
don't know if they all do that we use
some website called 16 personalities
that kind of give it to you so we all
have five letters
apparently this was actually used for a
while it's like something like
like concrete but i think yeah they're
like this is stupid like don't use this
to actually
draw any meaningful criticism that i
read specifically said that the metric
that it doesn't measure that it
should that more serious ones do is
neuroticism
um which there's a lot of that in this
building so yeah definitely we're
definitely missing a piece of the puzzle
here
yeah that's true it ignores like i feel
like it ign yeah you're right it ignores
the deeper more neurotic uh yes
but as just like kind of an overview of
your sort of archetype of your
personality type i think you know like
we all we all felt like ours was fairly
accurate when we looked at it okay so so
cameron olivia and sam backstage made
predictions what do you guys want me to
present this so you can just open it
it's just a it's just a spreadsheet um
uh all three of them were pretty
familiar with this uh ironically they're
the three that
aren't revealing theirs on the show so
they're making it but they all knew it
well enough to to make some predictions
uh about what um they think we all have
we they should have a mic shouldn't they
if they want to
okay by the way get over here olivia
kind of duped me because she took two
guesses at mine and they were both wrong
and i didn't i told her she couldn't
change her yeah you you didn't change it
did you olivia she she claimed she did
good yeah
cheater
yeah you guys got to get on the mic to
uh talk about gather round you can uh
use
oh yeah we should have introduced olivia
olivia come come on what did the letters
represent
um i don't know i think we'll figure i
don't know exactly uh i could tell you
um it's like intra introverted or extra
yes it's uh the first letter is either e
or i for extroverted or introverted yeah
oh interesting all my monitors just
turned off so
wait
a bunch of stuff just turned off what
just happened somewhere
are we still live
wait so what happened did we just lose
the whole show
it looks like we're live okay well we'll
check it out
are we still live no we're live yeah we
are we're looking live okay hold on just
a little technical issue here
[Music]
so as you can see here
um
cameron i guess just based on the e here
cameron and olivia think i'm extroverted
sam thinks i'm introverted
everybody said you're introverted elo
okay
everyone thinks dan's introverted
a.b
sam just said simp is that a
s-i-m-p i don't know so okay interesting
that's true
everyone thinks abe is extroverted zach
everyone thinks he's extroverted that's
for
mr uh i say hello to the grosser and
made her day better you bet your damn
ass i do
that ian is definitely introverted love
is definitely introvert okay so so these
seem like good guesses okay oh you guys
seem torn on me though
right
oh yeah good call
um i'm the only one that people were
torn on otherwise it was a unanimous
i can't zoom on it
a unanimous decision here
a percentage at the top oh there we go
yeah
um
okay dan's back
so do you guys so let's start with me i
guess and then you guys can kind of
i i feel like we need some more setup
here
all right
i'm trying to okay so introduce olivia
olivia has been our intern she is
fantastic we love olivia
um
and then so do you want to explain kind
of what you guys your thought process
here what these letters mean
and uh and
as we before we get into my
uh results here
yeah i think cam is more informed in the
like science
of it all there's a website called 16
personalities where it like gives you a
description of each person and like
names them like adventurer and they're
like classes in an rpg
so cool
take this
hello hello hey yeah so i mean i
wouldn't say i'm too informed on the
science of it but
you know i just uh just just explain so
the people can follow along sure i mean
it breaks down to extroversion intuition
uh extroversion intuition
sorry
very nervous to be on camera right now
extroversion
in introversion uh intuition
and what is sensation or observation is
the second category and then thinking
and
feeling is the third and then judging
and perceiving is the fourth i believe
and uh i think judging and perceiving is
the tricky one because it's judging
perceiving is
judging is a more
uh
it's like more whether or not
something's agreeable or not and then i
think perceiving is just
a talent or
a
an ability to
i and i'm probably gonna get this wrong
we get 10 million comments but something
you know perception of a thing okay so
so here so you guys all there was a
split on if i'm introverted or
extroverted so let me pull mine up
and uh
it looks like sam was the only one that
said i was introverted so let's start
there
now my score what i am
i am a [ __ ] adventurer yo
an assertive
explorer well that's the overall
category um
oh we got two adventurers in the
building
but so i'm confident individualism what
what does all this [ __ ] mean well if you
scroll down it uh it gives you a little
bit more of a breakdown
so you are extremely introverted yes i
am i actually am very introverted that's
surprising there was a lot of questions
like do you like would you rather go out
or stay in ethan doesn't want to go out
ever okay he doesn't want to do anything
there was one question was like do you
like group activities
[Laughter]
so i am actually extremely introverted i
would say
energy
i don't know what this means intuitive
versus observant actually i don't i
don't understand that
observant individuals are highly
practical pragmatic and down to earth
thank you
they tend to have strong habits and
focus on what is happening already has
happened okay
right nature
uh
ethan is mostly feeling
right on the edge there apparently
though
feeling individuals are sensitive and
emotionally expressive they are more
empathic and less competitive okay
the key
tactics
i'm very prospecting whatever that means
perspectives are very good at
improvising and spotting opportunities
tend to be flexible relaxed
non-conformist who prefer keeping their
options open that definitely sounds
right
that is extremely right thank you thank
you
this one i was very high very high
scoring on extremely assertive uh this
crate underpins all others showing how
confident we are in our abilities and
okay so interesting i didn't expect that
i would score so high on a service but
there you go yeah
yeah because you do
i would say because you you change your
mind on things a lot but i guess that's
not necessarily
i do change my i think that's more in
the um tactics right right the
prospecting yeah okay that's fair
yeah
okay interesting but there was one thing
i wanted to show you ela yeah on the i
think it's the assertive adventure
they go
wait god damn it where'd i find all this
[ __ ] here there's a link at the top of
the section i think is what you're
looking for that actually describes the
uh
the rpg classes
in detail oh yeah bro
wait that's what you missed
which one no this this link right here
yeah that's what i'm clicking
okay there's a part where it says he
does his work at night that's all i
wanted to say
says you do your best work at night that
is definitely true ethan is up at three
in the morning messaging us uh often
times so i don't know what to say my
whole life i just can't that's just when
i'm not when i'm alert
is the middle of the night i can't help
it i just you want to see my strengths
and weaknesses ila
my strengths are
i'm charming
true
i'm sensitive to others true you're very
close i'm imaginative true
i'm passionate and true this is just way
cool
like you said there's a little bit of
the astrology positive overall well this
is these are the good ones i'm curious
true i'm artistic that's true weaknesses
uh
hates uh what what could be funny
witness uh he doesn't want to leave the
house
fiercely
independent that's true i mean i i i'm
gonna say i'm fiercely it's almost like
a compliment though they can't be
negative
just tell it like it is i'm a pain i'm a
pain in the ass and here i have
something that like you don't like
traditions and hard rules that's true i
think
what were you gonna say again
uh on the actual on the adventures page
if you look at my screen over here it
tells you adventures you may know and do
you see that uh isn't that the guy from
uh
from bps
wait what
hey this is about me you are freaking
bts army dude
how do they know what their how did they
know what they would answer on this
maybe they did the thing at some point i
don't know
kevin costner is an adventurer too kevin
costner you and kevin hey
i'm such a proud adventurer now
look over i wanna see who else is in
there uh frida did you know dude britney
[Laughter]
you know what's funny i was looking
through some of these the other day and
they'll have a bunch of real people and
then they just randomly have fictional
characters i'm like you can't it's not
that doesn't work that way
i'm like there here's one
beatrix kiddo from kill bill you're like
the main character from kill bill and
jesse
shut up you guys don't remember the part
of the movie where she took the test
yeah
and the
the girl from rohan in lord of the rings
you're just like that right
basically they say i'm unpredictable
what do you think
dislikes long-term commitment
unpredictable yes 100 yeah yeah yeah
easily stressed
yeah overly competitive
pretty competitive yeah actually yeah
yeah with your family yes oh my god yeah
anytime we play a game on the show or
anything
fluctuating self-esteem i guess i mean i
don't know about that that's kind of
like who doesn't right experience
fluctuating yeah that one's pretty broad
okay but like generally pretty accurate
yeah yeah
oh romantic relations this is kind of
interesting now let's see
here elo this one's for you
i have a tender heart that's true
love from the soul that's true
that's it that's all i get
parenthood oh interesting shitty parent
doesn't care about any yeah finding joy
in the everyday i don't know what that
means i'm not reading it
the power of love okay they ran out of
it where's the one where it says that i
work at night
i don't worry i believe habits yeah
that's what i i need to show elo that
just as proof that you can
she can't get mad
workplace habits
uh
to my email
i don't know why they're keeping this
from me now this is the most important
thing i'm sure it's in there you made it
up it's the only thing that i really
cared about here you look on my phone
here fun facts about adventures
be most productive late in the evening
late in the evening evening is not like
late in the evening that's not three a.m
that's not like all night adventure
i'm a severe adventure okay so you guys
guessed that
it's kind of i'm not gonna lie it's kind
of hard to parse this data in a way
that is useful so today and so ins got
it right or isp
sorry isfp is what you got huh so nobody
got that nobody got it oh wow you're
unpredictable there was a lot of there
was a lot of contention on the
extroverted introverted yeah and also
the f these are these are all very
different yeah they're all different
hard up in town guys you're hard to pin
down all right let's do ela next what do
you guys think yeah so the predictions
for ela
were i s f j
i n f j bro that is so i s
f j so there was two isfjs
yeah
everybody had pretty similar predictions
there was just one one discrepancy
between the prediction okay this is
interesting assertive defender that
sounds right to me
they were right
wait
fj you guys isfj sam and cam both got
that right olivia was one letter off
you are us assertive uh
defender the bender
the carer she's a tank class
so wait what do i do i go strength and
weaknesses oh is that what i didn't
click on mine
are you ready ela strengths you are
supportive
you are reliable and patient you that's
true
that's very true
you have to be you are imaginative and
observant
you are enthusiastic
you are
loyal and hard-working you loyal you
loyal girl
good practical skills
got a vibe your weaknesses are humble
and shy that's very true that's not why
is that a weakness
shock i get shy
a weakness in in social settings you
know yeah
take things too personally do you think
so i'm not sure i agree with that
that one seems like a stretch for you
though you repress your feelings that's
probably true
overlor you overload yourselves that's
probably true
you are reluctant to change
it seems like a little
too ultra altruistic
what is that right
what does that mean you believe
altruistic is the world selflessness
oh you are altruistic yeah yeah
wait hold on sorry yeah that's right
where's the one where i was looking at
here
this is the one i found the most
interesting oh my god this website is
hard to navigate
where's the one i was looking at where
it showed
on a sliding scale all the trades
oh that was on her actual results oh
yeah here
so let's see
you are 80 introverted whoa
that was kind of close to what i got
this trait shows where we direct our
mental energy
you are 80 percent observant
i don't really understand
these broad general uh you are mostly
feeling
you are judging oh
judge
we were opposite on tactics i don't know
what that means though right
and then identity so this one i scored
really high on you are mostly assertive
okay
i guess i was highly assertive you were
extremely assertive yeah
okay
uh how did you feel you felt like that
was good pretty accurate you want to see
these defenders that you might know
there's some good ones here oh yeah yeah
yeah look at this
bro queen elizabeth oh vanessa
that's families
he's all about them yeah he was all
about family
aretha franklin
hallie barry
kate middleton how do they know
i mean who the [ __ ] knows lance riddick
selena gomez
samwise
[Laughter]
it says why hold on let's see why
oh dude oh this is so cheesy
yeah there is no way
yeah uh
i'm just glad that vin diesel's in there
will turner from pirates of the
caribbean
pam beasley from the office okay thank
you okay veto correlation
i'll take the godfather yeah you're the
[ __ ] godfather
yeah
from from pam to the god no no no no no
no no no no
you coming to my 16 personality zack how
could you
you call me
an assertive defender
i'm an adventurer
how dare you miss caterpillar
[Laughter]
i know it was you fredo
alfredo
afraido
okay let's go on to dan
dan the hater
so their uh their predictions for mine
was your wizard bro i infj
and
istj for both olivia and sam which uh
cameron is the one that got it right
and even got the letter right infja wow
bro i don't this whole acronym [ __ ] is
not working for me
it's so confusing but you're a wizard
dan you're a [ __ ] wizard we call you
the wizard you're a wizard that's pretty
weird actually with the little icons
all right
dan and i were talking about this last
night and i told him that's what i
thought he was and that was a part of my
guess guessing process too was that
there was a wizard there
you just picked the wizard yeah and some
other things that went into it but dan's
got a good moral compass and you know
he's got i said he has a good moral
compass and a
acute sense of aesthetics which kind of
led me to believe he was an idiot
yeah he has a cute no
what did you just call me sense of
aesthetic all right you're introverted
barely
he's a hater
it means i'm a hater exactly you're
highly imaginative
you're only imagining you are uh
a sensitive you are sensitive you're
right in the but to be honest with you
dan you're right on the middle here i'm
looking for strong indicators that's
true the biggest indicator here is that
you're intuitive
very imaginative open-minded and curious
you prefer novelty over stability and
focus on hidden meanings and future
potentials
seems fairly accurate you know
so that's it otherwise you're kind of on
the fence here quite a bit it says that
uh this the the advocate the one that i
am is the rarest of the personality
types oh oh my god bro it says you're so
rare it's i'm i'm built different you
are you are so rare right now all right
check out that check out these
check out the advocates you might know
nelson mandela
and martin luther king
mother teresa mother teresa this
advocate thing is so stupid
it's so dumb lady gaga
all right
not really a gaga head but
morgan freeman
johnson how the [ __ ] would they know if
gouta
he's like a fame he's like the
shakespeare of germany and he lived like
hundreds of years ago was it pretty cool
no idea i've seen on other websites
famous infjs are some of the world's
like baddest people too
oh just the they wouldn't put it on well
mother teresa was on there so there you
go
oh this one says charles manson actually
also among
uh prison break like who oh atticus
finch is
you're saying i'm nothing like atticus
finch i'm saying you're more like osama
bin laden
all right well they don't they don't
list him here unfortunately so not
obviously your desire for not forcing
your blowers but you guys are both
passionate individuals and we believe in
things and we both want death to the to
the americans oh jesus
[Laughter]
all of them is also an infj
infj if you know who i'm talking about
look no no no a h i don't want to say
his name but oh really yeah army death
to all sorry are you talking about
hitler yeah yeah you just say his name
oh yeah adolf hitler is also an infj oh
[ __ ]
wait where are you getting that data
from we gotta give another website you
know it's just as legitimate as oh i
wanna see the baddies i want to see
the worst people that are each one and
they have them they have a breakdown
there's some website that i've seen that
has a breakdown for every sign too of
the good and the bad
uh i'll i'll go and pull it up and then
i'll link it if you're interested so we
really gotta not push then too far yeah
i might snap in life
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it says actually of the uh what was it
called the the advocates it says don't
push them too far yeah
they will they will
all right this is a b let's see what
this uh yeah so the predictions for a b
uh everybody said the extroverted
everybody was an e variation e n f p e n
t p e n t j so actually three different
guesses on this one but everybody's
saying extroverted
and everybody's saying
uh whatever the n means you think you're
a mat you think you're a people master
uh a b that's what it says here i don't
think anything i just that's
good
as a people person all right let's get
to the bottom thank you dan he's the
assertive executive
okay
we have some big uh
you so you're extroverted like we all
expected
you like group settings and stuff maybe
you like group projects
group projects or group settings well
they add there was one question i
remember that like do you like group
projects i don't like [ __ ] that i'm not
always a fan of group projects working
here is probably the first time that i
am but i i like group settings for other
things just like hanging out of course
but fascinating
[Laughter]
so you're right on the middle here on
energy nature here's a big one
judging
you're a judge you're judging judging
yeah you were high on judging as well
decisive thorough and highly organized
that's true you guys both are very
you guys you mean you very organized
definitely
sticky notes calendars [ __ ] like that
i have a little nickname at the office
given to me by zach
the dictator as well
i want to say for the record that i very
much appreciate your thank you you've
lost a lot of friends along the way
you what i've lost a lot of friends
along the way yeah well not me i think i
got you and dan left you got my respect
i will always be your friend amy thank
you buddy
oh this is never mind so you're highly
organized uh you like clarity
predictability and closure i need that
clout you prefer you like clout as says
here
uh and then the other thing you scored
high on oh that was it just that one
and some uh famous executives you may
know uh judge judy
uh sinatra
okay
uh james monroe i guess what am i just
old london people
johnson boromir you know what boredom
dwight is so stupid
oh boy
so dumb oh you guys see the end of the
memes on that oh she calls me
white already how are you are you the
dwight to ethan's michael wow
oh my god definitely could be ian do you
think michael is an explorer
huh i'm jim michael scott may have been
an explorer
you were a venturer right weren't you or
was it exploding
i'm gonna mix between wait hold on abby
thinks he's jim i'm a mix between jim
and dwight i'd say wouldn't do i think
yeah
exactly yeah i think
false dan is toby and oscar
uh i could see the toby for sure because
i'm the one that always has i think
uh i think the office personality roles
are more accurate
[Laughter]
stupid-ass quiz
oh actually uh interestingly ap it says
that you are very similar uh in
personality to um uh
a pole pot
famous mass murderer
i need that clout
all right up next we've got um
zach there's got to be some neurotic
[ __ ] on this axe yeah i'm interested in
sex you're a turt oh stupid zack you've
you're a turbulent protagonist girl
so olivia
and cam got that right sam
dude you're a turbulent protagonist
okay i just blew my mind when i got oh
you got high you have higher is it
really a surprise the guy that was off
the charts on the narcissism scale
thinks he's the main character i just
don't believe he's taking this quiz
honestly i was crazy my hand to god
all right okay so let's see uh you are
extroverted we all knew that
did you did you make anyone's week by
saying hi to
um them trying to think
there's this dude at the gas station
that's really cool oh yeah tell me about
your interactions with you no he's just
cool like you know
what's his name
uh mark okay cool shout out to mark what
do you guys talk about no it's just like
you know i'll go in and be like hey
oh what's up dude you know it's like oh
can i get 20 on pump 3 you know i can
see why you want a documentary made
about your life sounds really
interesting
what's so cool about him
i'm just trying to be friendly okay yeah
i mean you know it's anything to
brighten someone's day absolutely
absolutely
all right so you are intuitive that
means uh you're imaginative open-minded
and curious you prefer novelty over
stability you're more like me in that
regard
you are feeling you're an emotional man
that is sensitive emotional
you are empat and
empathic and less competitive my
nickname in elementary school is the
gentle giant i think i've said that
before
interesting
yeah i mean
i
very sensitive boy yeah we love you for
it
i actually i want to get into a little
bit deeper here on zack
if we go to this you can see here let's
go straight to the weaknesses
[Laughter]
you're unrealistic
[Laughter]
uh you are overly idealistic
basically i'm getting too delusional
condescending bro
it says you're condescending mine aren't
that bad i don't think that's accurate
no i don't think zack's condescending at
all um not playing he's not but he does
joke a lot about being condescending in
a joking way interesting i didn't is he
joking okay
now according to this
he's intense overly empathic just like
shane dawson
nice comparison zach really is a big
empath i feel
all right let's move on to ian who
doesn't exist wait wait real quick can i
just see who i'm like compared to yes
you're like barack obama uh oprah
winfrey
john cusack ben affleck all right wow a
lot of common memes on the show are
showing up in the
personality things uh you're like malala
you're like sean connery okay love
jennifer lawrence maya angelou i don't
know
daenerys
she went [ __ ] psycho and killed
everybody spoiler alert
uh freaking morpheus here i'm seeing one
it says like uh john kozinski
yeah una bomber very much in similar
great compliment even the oracle
fundamentals how can you be you can't
you can't be morpheus and the oracle
well-developed character yeah she's in
like your scenes how are you gonna put
her oracle
tyler white who wants to i'm just that
cool man skylar white that's rough
skylar
yeah
damn that's by far the worst i've seen
on here
more evil than walt yeah
that's rough people hate skylar all
right ted kaczynski
right
i'll take it man whatever i know that
obama's on here just straight up
okay so ian doesn't exist as we know so
they guessed for ian the same as me kind
of except they're like no they gave infj
which is the one that i got everybody
guessed ian's to be that
oh right so for some reason this is
honest not to is just an image uh but
that's okay oh you're right he's
screenshotted so ian you're also a
[ __ ] wizard ian you're a wizard ian
you ready he's also the wizard um
oh i can't i'm back wait i thought dan
you were saying that's the rarest one
yeah i'm starting to doubt that
i'm starting to doubt that it's really
that rare
two of us are uh well well hold on kind
of odd that there's only a screenshot uh
oh you think he manipulated this do you
think he faked it
they're like you are a
i mean the number two
i don't know well the only one he scored
off the chart was energy
he's very intuitive
yeah i was much more centered on most of
these
yeah actually he is for the most part
too
ian and i are just the same dude the
only one that we're completely different
is the last one identity i was assertive
he's turbulent
which i think i i think actually whoa
whoa whoa whoa love
you're off the charts here dude on all
of them
off the charts but always in the hard
assertive logician
wow you skipped the head to love
yeah okay we don't give a [ __ ] about it
again well i'm just trying to move it
along yeah i thought he enjoyed loving
the club man
you want to give him you want dan was in
the middle of thanksgiving it's all good
whatever go ahead go ahead
i already said it's just
it was just an image i'm just doing
anything with that
you just didn't go you just sent me
rewind
what am i supposed to do with the
screencap dance i said
i screenshot i go is this cool everybody
went great
i didn't know that y'all got these links
you all got these little images
you're the only one that's sending an
image and i think that says a lot about
your personality
i'm just saying
all right what who's who what famous
people are liking him
it was the same list as mine it's the
same rewind yeah
i was just saying
he and i are flipped on our uh what was
it tactics or whatever this one says
actually it says ben shapiro
you're a lot like
keyword is female genitalia right
[Laughter]
love actually has the most interesting
results because as you can see here he's
scoring really high on all of them
what is he he's the law very introverted
which we guessed
i'm surprised so introverted with all
the fika going on over there
[Laughter]
you're very intuitive
you're very thinking
was he the only one on the crew that got
thinking
i think we were all feeling
thinking individuals focus on
objectivity and rationality prioritizing
logic over emotion
they tend to hide their emotionalness i
mean he is a [ __ ] robot yeah
literally a robot yeah did anybody guess
it
uh the guesses for love were i n t j i s
t j i s t p guys was he any of those
means nothing
it does mean something you just have a
hard time remembering bro do you really
does anyone really remembering the four
letters it's four letters
ipg lmo
rt you guys are gonna say i'm simping
but i check out every time you guys say
the letters i check out yeah okay i have
not followed anything
that's why i struggle to describe it
because it's so many like no
you've given him an impossible dad all
right
you you're claiming you can it's four
letters either like what are you talking
about it's not that difficult
[Music]
it's not that it's not that it's hard to
remember four letters it's just i can't
like conceptualize okay
anyway whatever doesn't matter uh you
are uh you are thinking love uh the one
only one here
yeah
the only one with the brain on this
group
but it actually yeah it makes so much
sense he is a robot like looking back to
the to the compliment battle
love actually just smashed us all on
it's funny right as you said that a chat
message this explains the long battle
between love and ian
interesting
i just feel like this this one is like
explaining that i'm boring
everything in the
every single one of them you you coded
and curated uh ethan's feet all on your
own too so i mean that shows that you
have you got a big brain on you
right yeah yeah that was some advanced
programming skills
years of practice
fika for life right love thank you for
life yeah well there you have it guys uh
interesting stuff
kind of applause everybody
round of applause
the one takeaway is that you look you
can't you have to let me stay up as long
as i want because according to this test
that's when i do my best work tell that
to theodore
you'll be sleeping
i do tell him to him when he wakes up
and i go get him
all right
okay okay
we got more fun stuff here on the
horizon
yeah we have a lot
you oh god we have
okay here i'll give you some options
either okay
do you want only fans banning uh
explicit content
or do you want cameo talk
or do you want benny boy
i we can't not talk about the cameo
boy putting that out i just want to get
it over with dude benny boy is really
good benny boy is really good too benny
boy is one
bunny boy and cameo okay
so my entire tick tock page is
absolutely over fl this is 90 of all i
see right now is this benny boy memes
so there's this guy on tiktok called
bentilect
and he's actually very popular he has 8
million followers on tick tock but his
content is really i mean let's say
very so flowy
it's like so float to a new level i'll
just scroll through a few and and then
you you'll get the idea of what kind of
content things that just make sense
universal power plugs absolute genius
silent garbage trucks we can only wish
universal tupperware lids they need to
make this pick and choose cable tv
channels that is amazing stickers that
show avocados are ready okay we need
that a button on the tv that makes the
beep elite a popcorn bowl with colonel
strainer this is the best
things that just make family and friends
he basically just
he steals content from twitter and
reddit and instagram
and then kind of curates it with like
really cringy
commentary and he says like facts a lot
like here okay better than having kids
me silence and money
and he thank you i think he's on social
media me types aggressively for one
minute
august is like if sunday we're a month
facts why is it when someone says be
safe the most unsafe people like myself
say always
approachable when really i look
i'm not a licensed therapist but if you
then mow me 25 bucks i'll try my best
yeah i mean it's super unfunny he laughs
at everything and he goes fast wow but
he's really popular you know that's
painful yeah it it is it is facts you
didn't know about astrology leos are
more likely to hit the gym i actually
never knew that capricorns have
wandering eyes i could see it aries make
up the bulk of billionaires that's crazy
top athletes are frequently aquarius
that actually makes sense gemini switch
jobs more i'm a gemini and that's facts
oh my god yeah i mean he posts a lot
every day it's getting millions but yeah
he's super popular
so here's where
it all goes sideways for benny boy
is that people have been clowning on him
because his content's so bad yeah
and they were due wedding him and
meaning on him and it got to the point
where he he turned off duets on all his
videos okay and then they went into his
comments and he had to turn off the
comments in all the videos and so now
people have taken it to a new level
and this i'm telling you
my whole feed is these games
let me show you one and then i'll try to
explain what we're looking at
so people started downloading
people started downloading his videos
and doing like creepy pasta with it
right
so the meme format is you cut it and
then you do a creepypasta and you
pretend that you're like watching him or
in his wall or something watch
is that funny ben my body just asked for
water so this is someone was like y'all
having a field day on support this girl
did a compilation of uh all the this is
basically what my feed looks like right
now a little bit mini donut because
nobody tells me what we're living in
your walls
nice swimming pool this is amazing teddy
bear ceiling lights absolute
this is not this one's kind of uh
ruining the joke a little bit because
they're covering it so let's ignore that
one
so here let's do this need a pure one
okay here benny boy in high school you
no longer do come meet me all over again
same but don't come here
oh benny boy
you look elegant when you sleep at night
just don't open the wardrobe benny boy
so yeah it's like creepypasta like
hugging him like why did you turn off
duets but
you think you can get rid of us that
easy
and my whole maybe it's because i was
interacting because i thought it was so
entertaining
but this is my whole freaking feeling
i gave it a mini donut because nobody
tells me what to do ben the smell of
your hair when you're sleeping fills me
with tranquility
don't stare at the dark corner in your
room ben
no it's turned into a huge viral it's
like a huge rival trend these are all
different people
i mean here you guys can see my document
these are just ones that i casually
pasted
there's hundreds i was really close to
making my own to be honest with you yolo
so any boy
i'm a little tick tock challenge but
like you just put the text and there's a
voice that you pick
yeah you can do voice over and then pick
the voice exactly like tech but there's
one that's like a demon voice like that
i think there's a deep one yeah there is
i don't know if it's still there they
may have removed it now but yeah
yeah
yeah
i'll turn on a two-hour movie just to
eat my food in two minutes and 15
seconds that two minutes
oh my gosh creepy took me to get into
your closet benjamin
yeah it's super creepy
i just i can't imagine what uh
you know he's been taking it in good
spirits he did he did some jokes
acknowledging it like looking in his
closet and be like in there
that's nice to see that he's making it
in stride i would be so [ __ ] creepy
it is scary yeah it's pretty creepy
can you try to find his his videos of
him acknowledging the meme this is
amazing this is a single photo absolute
genius the road that's stunning
stop running binny boy you're in your
walls
[Laughter]
sunset this is amazing
and every time i would share one it
would just show me more it was like
everyone
wow yeah that's pretty amazing barry
and it's got a lot of likes too 200 000
likes that means it's got probably got
millions of views living their best life
this dog aka the birdmaster yes a horse
and a cat being basti's goals a
mousetrap goals benjamin turning off
stitches isn't going to do anything in
your wall holes living their best life
this dog aka the berm and the pictures
they find are just like
yes bro
so this is benny boy on tick tock
bentlex that's amazing yeah that's
pretty much that's one thing i love
about tick tock is that sometimes people
just take [ __ ]
so the next level look at this that's
240 000 likes
let me just see if i can find the views
on this
thank you
this guy is just dedicated to ben
here 2 million 2 million views this is
like serious views square watermelons
okay these don't exist
the square watermelons look pretty real
to me benny boy
square watermelons okay these are this
one is two million he has quite a lot
over five million
if he scrolls further down there benny
boy yeah yeah no he's spot he's popular
to eat my food in two minutes and 15
seconds that two minutes and finishes
how long this guy's a connoisseur so
here's band acknowledging the the meme i
was a little worried about him but uh
he's taking it in good stride here
here's benny boy
part one
hello
is anybody there
[Music]
um hello is anybody there hello
hello
hello
i can't say i'm loving this one
oh no no no i need to make a reaction
this one's like bunny boy
you think making a sketch will make us
go away
look under your bed
i'm sure there's hundreds of those
already
here's a second benny boy acknowledging
this is the one i this is the one i saw
that i thought was good
and open your closet
ben look out the window
i'm in your walls bad
i'm under your bed benjamin
don't get i hm okay benny even this
it's for it's rough
it's rough for benny boy i mean i have
the same cycle with all these reaction
type channels like same thing with james
like he was taking everyone's content
for so long and then he started doing
his own sketches and it was just like
but jinx had to adapt because i think
this guy's got a bright career on tick
though oh yeah definitely you can you
can do this forever man
[Music]
dog's paws look like tiny koala bears
that's
3.3 million
views therapist you saw the red flags
though right me i thought it was the car
is that funny benjamin
we are beginning to grow tired of these
games
therapists you saw the red dogs paw have
errands to run the air
[Laughter]
yep
that's a pure one that's not no games
so there you go that was what my weekend
was um
just looking at that
the benny boy uh saga did anyone else
see those on their page or was it just
me
i don't use tick tock i i saw i didn't
see as many as you did i saw maybe one
or two yeah okay
when i saw his face i think i recognized
it but i don't think i let it go get to
the point of you know the transition i
think i probably swiped up before you
didn't yeah you they so they're like
he's not interested
i love the ben the hey you want to show
off your shirt baby you want to work it
for me
you look good and you're like you know
damn look at that that's out on teddy
fresh now
jerry garcia um
some people are asking about the shirt
that you are wearing oh this shirt comes
out at the end of the month right next
next week next week on thursday yeah
the collection coming out this week is
so far bro or next week
but the one that's out now is so fire
too you want how do you like that shirt
baby i love it actually and i wanted to
show i wish i brought the tag with me i
kind of want to go grab one i'll go grab
one i actually do want to show it too
and it's so cool
dude ela genius attached on the tag a
freaking jerry garcia teddy fresh pick
special edition teddy fresh yeah did you
know that that yeah is that did you get
that
i actually tested it out he was the beta
tester yeah before um oh you did yeah
it's a very high quality
i have to it's not like a thin it's
actually a solid
thick pick yeah
i love it
and i'm very much looking forward to
getting mine uh shirts
i love you zach
and i'm in your walls
[Laughter]
i'll wait for um ab but um
so we'll do cameo next we have some
pretty funny cameo updates oh we should
talk about of though
we've never even yeah we can talk i
don't think we've talked about even the
fact that these guys are on cameo so
okay right um thank you so yeah here's
the shirt that but it comes with i don't
know if you can show a close-up with
your camera
uh a b
yeah
i thought that was so cool
that is a very cool thing
freaking genius
that is a great idea let me see
uh it's a little dark but
you're just trying to show the pick yeah
hold on i got it right here oh
work it work it
work
and as i i got to say as a
big deadhead you guys nailed it like
thank you it's very cool
well we are too actually is teddy fresh
oh yeah garcia in the back i'm a huge
fan of the grateful dead and
specifically i love
jerry garcia so
we pursued that one and uh it was really
cool what are you selecting i'm like
because i just ran so damn fast to go
upstairs and find this shirt for like
one of those and dan's like oh i got it
oh i got right here i didn't realize we
were trying to show the pick
little workout let's talk about of
because i know maybe we should i don't
know i don't want to get like
let's keep it loose just keep it fun
yeah let's dry day baby yeah let's do
cameo's
this guy
or a girl i actually don't know is there
any donors to read that i wear the
corduroy shorts all the time and i've
gotten compliments so thanks for
watching
the av was wearing last week
i don't know if
this might be a girl it's a sarita
but either way
oh i'm glad you like your pants thank
you so much yeah that's awesome
we love that you loved it
you know
um uh
okay let's talk about cameo these guys
so here's what's been going on cameo
all these guys gone on cameo i hear i'd
be already stressing
why are you stressing maybe
all right
there's nothing wrong with your cameos i
don't
actually nothing could be as bad as my
voice is cracking like that
are you embarrassed about your cameo
baby
i'm more focusing on my voice right now
you know what's interesting okay what
was interesting to me is what people set
their prices at
my mom is on cameo she's at 50. ab set
his at 70.
and i was like wow i mean wow i mean
good for you for believing in yourself
but i was like
like zack's at 50. ian was at 30 because
he doesn't exist
but abe how do you justify the 70 price
tag
oh well that was kind of just a meme for
a little bit because i was at
i was at 55 and zach was at 40 or i was
at 50 and then zach was at 40. so then
zach put his to 50.
and so to mess with him i'm like all
right then i'm 70. but then i put it
back down 55.
you guys won't see an example of a visa
ticked cameos i swear to god i told them
i was like guys i'm cool with you guys
doing cameos but my one rule is that
they all have to be public
right so that we can audit them yeah
and see [ __ ] like this for the show
dude av what the [ __ ] is this
people cameos that looked like this and
you got a one star right
this guy gave me two stars
i had to explain to him what happened
and then he changed five stars
[Laughter]
did you do a new one for him yeah i did
i figured out the problem actually i
just figured it out well at first i was
recording on my big camera because i was
trying to do like 4k cameos with you
know good audio and video there's your
problem yeah i know i'm just trying to
give him some premium all content but
then uh 4k
zach re-recorded his intro with his
girlfriend's phone and it came out
messed up like this yeah i realize it's
a problem with
iphone 12. do you usually stand up when
you do cameos baby are you usually just
laying down in bed or whatever
i'm yeah that was the thing it wasn't
just that it was all scuffed looking
like this you were laying in
what's bed i don't know why you don't
show any effort listen listen i got
requests backed up the ass all right
like i do you really how many do you
have pending how many do i have right
now i don't think that has anything to
do with the quality of that i'm just
saying i feel like the people that are
booking me know me and they like me for
whatever i am how many guys are sincere
how many you got how many of you i got
pending penny i have five right now okay
i mean
not that crazy that's fine he slammed
we made it sound like you had like a
hundred i mean it's almost like at a
thousand it's it's up there in just one
week wait how many have you done so far
how many have you gotten
i think i've gotten
nearly 20. that's great what about yo
zack has been the king of cameos so
thank you thank you did you put it zach
does jack does all this uh
let's see let's open zach's
zach how many have you gotten uh 26.
wow
and you serenade people right i will
write an original song or like they'll
send me suggestions like hey can you
play over there can you play his intro
video oh wait i wanted to see the one
that abe sent
wait hold on sorry i i i and dan is the
only one who's not doing it yeah i
refuse to do that i'm not i'm you cannot
pay me enough to do that wait where's
the video of av being like sorry my
cameo was bad here's another one
isn't there video
i don't think we have that because
here it is i found it a cameo from me uh
my cameos have been turning out like
[ __ ] because i like trying
on my my good camera i thought it was
i'm trying to make some high quality 4k
cameos but i guess whenever i was
uploading it the yeah i thought there
was one you sent someone that was like
sorry that one was so bad here's another
one that was the the two-star guy who
ended up being a very nice guy and
changed it to five-star that's oh that's
so awkward
yeah let me swatch your your uh
let me watch your intro i didn't do that
you see you changed it your other your
other intro was
well here it is what's up guys it's a b
from the h3 podcast i'm excited to be on
cameo and i'm really excited to be
taking your guys money i mean requests
oh i
shoot how do i redo this
what's up guys
he also recorded one where he was
intimidating me which was actually
really funny i'm sorry impersonating me
where he wears a hawaiian shirt oh my
gosh
that was actually pretty great it was
very funny that one was good but i
didn't want to get in the way of zack
wait are you filming this at work bro
katie what's up i heard it's your 20th
birthday
[Music]
this mind you i'm here from eight to
like you know i'm the first one to go
yeah yeah you work hard but like so when
did you film this one what's up and i
tried to put it against the birth of
like a flat and your friends i wasn't
trying to cry that's obviously worse
and they said that you deserve the world
what do you what are you holding uh
michael
bro
are you guys all filming cameos at work
i'm not i do it at home
ian you filming cameos at work
uh i did the first one kind of as a joke
you can see it on one of you so let me
get this straight in because i'm paying
you
can you hold it
could you hold that thought and watch
the ends
and then yell at me wait i want to hear
your message katie what's up i heard
it's your 20th birthday
and uh your friends you want to just
maybe you want to just sit at my desk
that'd be a nice value ad probably
sit right before watch
watch ian
please and thank you dan did you know
they were doing this at work no no
completely unaware
who the [ __ ]
[ __ ] did
you know he might have been
on saturdays
there's no off the clock you're you're
here yeah so what's the difference but
all of them are at work i look how many
of them are at work no not only ones
that were oh it's just showing the same
three yeah
i thought it was showing um
i thought it was showing and i needed to
get that one in so i keep my 24 hour
status okay let's listen
what's up that's your 20th birthday
and uh your friends
ella griffin
wanted me to send you some love and they
said that you deserve the world
and that uh
they're there for you
we're sweet people my friends don't even
answer the phone what what a beautiful
group of people they're a little shallow
because i'm hearing that they're team
jacob so they are a little shallow but i
think they might really get into this
shout out to you
but yeah they said that you're very hard
working and that you're in med school so
congrats to you on that
don't be embarrassed man be proud of
your words i knew this day was coming
you know to get some cash on the side i
think it's cool to do a little side
hustle thank you i'm happy for you guys
i really am i think it's cool
i mean you guys could be living like uh
white cloud game right
they got a ways to go until they get
like game levels
oh this is going to help a lot though i
think
but i'm i'm i i love the saga i really
do let's move on to zach
so you've done like 20 zap well zach
is out here serenading man like crazy
watch his intro video if you haven't
seen it how come i'll say if you you'll
definitely get more than your money's
worth with zach zach goes all out
write you a nice song here's that he's
doing that [ __ ] showing off the feet
[Applause]
why are you killing your bare feet like
that it wasn't
me it was no slam at you that is
disrespectful to me it was no slam at
you i wanted to frame it
did you purposely do bare feet no my
hand to god no
what is this you sent me
that was zack's flipped version of the
same video
okay let's watch the feet defeat uh
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
oh
you play guitar in all of them uh zach
usually yeah
do people request songs
yeah they do
julian first and foremost oh they don't
know how to stop the other video
okay chill cameo so like this one
this dude like shot me a message on
cameo and he's like hey if i email you
my track can you jam over it hmm oh
interesting little collab
yeah i mean he made a beat of my laugh
from like an episode have you do you
guys have any um any weird requests yet
um
i i got like an anti-semitic one that i
refused no
he's like he's like hey can you
make fun of fun of my jewish friend with
like curly hair and a big nose oh
what the [ __ ] good job because you put
that out there bro and it's out there
yeah i would i would i'm not the sound
lad out there
right can i know i'm a jew myself so you
know um yeah what's up jew boy yeah
exactly
like you know i'm personally i i i can
speak for a b and e and like very
careful of what we
say you know it's usually very pg
ian got a pretty interesting request you
want do you talk about that one tell me
uh well i got it this morning um no
that's not what i'm talking about yeah
the one i i was telling you earlier
about i think i heard about this one
there's another one the one in the
private messages that you tell me about
that oh
yeah someone wanted to see my little
piggy wigglies
someone asked to see ian's feet but what
was interesting is that ian was really
considering sending him feed pics right
did you end up doing it
i didn't do it i was talked out of it
so he was offering me 50 bucks i was
like i show the feet i want to talk
about feet but also don't do the [ __ ] it
wasn't just feet it was like he wanted
to do a really weird pose too right it
was a very awkward that was the thing is
that first i thought they were just
memeing because we'd have all the defeat
memes on the show but the request was so
oddly specific that it it became
apparent that no this
this person wants to jack off to the
internet what was the pose that they
were requesting
it was like um
like me with my feet all the way out and
yeah like that all right my face he's
empty and then this was interesting
that's how i knew it was weird the guy
sent a photo of himself doing the pose
that he wanted ian to do
and he was gonna tip you too man
yeah he was saying uh
50 bucks a video so this was going to
become a regular thing yeah
well he was supposed to be doing i was
like that's just you don't want that you
don't want that
you don't want that fifty dollars trust
me you but you said
next never mind well it's just like i
mean
i don't know i don't i feel no
connection
so
like it does it didn't bother me it
didn't feel like a violation it doesn't
bother you but on the internet there's
going to be some weird jerk off video
it's like getting paid 50 bucks to show
my elbow or something i don't care okay
well how about this what if
you have you know what tribute videos
are in oh no
so you want to teach the class okay so
tribute video is like when somebody
pleasures himself and finishes on a
photo of someone
so you're gonna be start having like
tribute photos of your feet on like the
hub you know what i mean it's just i've
trust me you're not ready for the
consequence of setting that video
i love that you're just putting this
energy up
i i
i think i did the right thing stopping
you from sending them
if that's the case there's a bunch of
photos out there me and zach
it's the intention it's the intent
yeah there probably are tribute picks
for you guys though already probably
but ian you had what was interesting to
me is like you i would send a picture of
my you know privates for what what was
your price
he's at 50 bucks no he said he said
he said two you said 250 for whole i
never said that
but no okay i mean no i'm not i'm not
going to told you anything but like if
somebody wanted to buy a picture of that
you said that you'd be willing to sell
it for a certain price no
i think you said
well
i'm trying to remember what it was i
think it was
i said if you gave me a tesla i'd show
my dick okay so then i was like oh yeah
you said for a nice new car so what i
said like 15 20. he said 20 20 000 you'd
show your dick on the internet
i mean i need a car man
she said
she said the first she's hearing about
it would you be okay with with that for
20k
sam was like sell your feet pics dude
she was pro
yes
yeah she's like no problem with feet
okay what about what about dick
no they know that what about a hole
[Laughter]
i was making a joke that sam was pimping
out ian for 18 bucks
after his cut when he was at thirty
dollars
eighteen bucks
ian would you like art ian ela would you
let me sell a dick pic for like a
million bucks or something
nft that there's anyone buying
mmp
would you be okay with that
no
no
that's pretty good deal though
so let's see what uh zach is uh let's
see what julian first and foremost i
have to say this is
so flattering the song you sent me like
it is so cool that you made a beat out
of it and um
took my laugh my insane
joker brain laughs and maybe um
[ __ ] a trap beat to it that's so cool
i'm very flattered
so
i thought i'd uh try and jam over it um
give it my best shot and um
[Music]
oh
yo this is content this is
[Music]
[Laughter]
i will write an original song jam over
anything yeah he's got a perfect
five-star uh score abe did too
reviews maybe you had a perfect uh five
score
did you you got that one guy to flip his
his
he lobbied you lobbied hard
let's watch ian's intro okay so ian took
his cameo in a whole different direction
just just to sign out he wins any intro
video he wins all right you guys ready
for answer how many orders have you got
ian you how are you doing compared to
the other guys
um
well i i keep opening it for a little
burst and then closing it because
i i don't know i haven't uh
i i put too much time in and i i get
bogged down so
so you're actually considerate
of other obligations in your life like
working here
one could say you know i got a photo for
you
here you want to see it here
wait wait there's something weird going
on um
i click in ian's and then it just brings
me back to this page like what the
fridge
and then when i click a b it does the
same thing oh sax
same thing what's happening it's flip
dude
thing is flip this is a screen cap from
ian's from your other star employees
what is that what am i even looking at
that's a screen cap from their cameo is
this supposed to be a gotcha yeah what
do you wait what am i is that james
charles
wait i genuinely don't understand what
i'm looking at would you come up to me
if you saw me in a mall they're at work
yeah they're in the back or they're in
the stairwell
bathroom no it's from it could be
literally anywhere dude
well i don't know what's happening here
ian ian was sending a birthday message
to someone and he's like hey do you want
to be i don't know i'm not saying
there's anything wrong with it but i'm
saying he was calling me out for doing
well because you're doing it on the
[ __ ] side labs at work
[ __ ]
harry potter
you knew i was gonna call you out for
doing that for what doing that work yeah
i was in front of a black wall
all right that's fair i'm in front of a
black wall they're acknowledging they're
using the office for doing your [ __ ]
side hustle at work
that was ask cameron cameron was here
that was like at eight o'clock where i
stayed after for like three hours while
cam was still you work hard you work
hard i won't question that you work hard
i won't demand you for that you you do
work really hard
it's just funny just that you're doing
camera hold on come on i have here no no
i listen i i trust i believe you you
work hard there's one more element to
this story too uh in that specific camp
i'm going to be a tattletale tale now uh
yeah tell me everything
in that cameo specifically that a b
showing they're joking about that they
got to get back to work oh damn yeah oh
okay
sorry guys bro
all right guys we gotta get back to work
for him enough enough having someone on
my side
we gotta get back to work thank you
cameron i'm gonna count on you to snitch
on everyone else it was at the end of
the day when i was like
i know you guys work hard i'm not joking
ab especially worked very hard
which i do we should just show this
camera if you can get to i can't open
anything i literally does cameo work for
you
maybe it crashes it actually is not
working people trying to
access like it genuinely is that
possible i mean oh my god it does not
work uh it's so awkward wait did we
[Music]
none of us it works it doesn't work for
me it doesn't work for me it doesn't
work for ela it doesn't work for dan
right we're ip banned
oh my god
wait let me try
incognito
maybe they have a different server for
sweden is that possible
no we crashed
we literally crashed cameo
you guys question the power we have here
we we do this all the time
the website's live we crash it like oh i
was able to get to ian's just now okay
he's working on my phone okay okay
let me try again here
cam yeah it just i don't know
it doesn't work
i guess i did something to piss off the
instagram god well while we wait for
cameo to get to come back online here
okay
all right so this is ian wait ian you
don't know how many you've gotten
uh i mean when i had it open i think i
did like seven or eight
what do you mean so it's not so people
can request it now they can't now it's
open right now
yeah he actually i had it turned off for
about uh he raised his price last night
he was like listen i have a lot of work
to do
i'm gonna close this right well yeah
because
i was doing like edits for him and then
after cameo and apple's cut i got uh 18.
so here's the crazy thing that is crazy
when you guys see it says 50 bucks for a
cameo we were kind of all come to this
realization like cameo takes what 25
percent and he said that's reasonable
right here's the thing about apple just
apple if you have an android this
doesn't apply to you at all this is so
mind-blowing apple takes 30
off the top of all in-app purchases
and that's four cameos cut so apple is
actually making more
than carryout than cameo it is it is
wild that is so cool do you guys
actually how can they justify that i
know it's it's it's it's authoritarian
it's it's oh my god
i mean it's better to book through web
you got it yeah web or android but like
bro how that how do they get away with
that like if it's a fake
apple is getting sued by a bunch of
companies for that reason yeah i mean
yeah that shouldn't be allowed that's
crazy that's what it's like cameo buying
it's like so
not any of their business
well if you buy it through their payment
portal or whatever you know what i mean
they they think that they deserve a cut
it's not even through their payment
portal it's anything anything but just
anything yeah if you use your own visa
with the app
right that you downloaded from apple
store they get a cut
wow yeah so like on a 60 camera you're
walking away with like 31 bucks it's
less than half you end up less than half
yeah because they take they both take
full cut yeah so
before the apple if it's just a cameo
cut if it's 50 it ends up being like
37.50 that's a such a big difference but
that's what we're saying is look on the
web but
but like yeah i remember when fortnite
got in a huge fortnight lawsuit with
with apple because apple was taking so
much
people were playing this game fortnite
and you can only imagine how much money
apple was just taking from them it's
probably just insane yeah fortnite
anyway go ahead and play ian's
intro well i've hit rock bottom at the
top of the world i'm on cameo if you ask
me to jump i say depends on how high
that bank account goes baby
so i need you to buy in so i could sell
out so happy birthday jessica and
congrats on them well
that's great ian yeah you want to tell
me about that that's great
i don't know that's what i mean is i get
bogged down and then i mean that's a lot
of work to do that yeah yeah ian's are
really really good
high production but it's fun it's like
making little mini sketches it's fun
and i've sold out
big time oh ian wrote here
uh if you buy don't use iphone app apple
takes that thirty percent thirty percent
isn't it
it is it's brutal it is brutal when i
saw that i spent like
there was one cameo i did i spent like
45 minutes editing it let me see it and
then i got like 17 bucks
and i was like this is brutal
astronomical let me see let me see uh
which is the one you spent a lot of time
on or which is the one you want to show
us that you that you're most proud of
here
well that's what i did last night on the
far left with the striped shirt you want
that watch that one
yeah we could do that one okay go ahead
dan
and just turn it down a little bit so we
all don't yeah yeah
this is a message for susan and colin
louise told me that it's your one year
wedding anniversary congratulations guys
that's very exciting and here's to many
more to come
i've actually been married once before
myself
it was a common law marriage with a
virginia possum that lived inside my
wall
[Music]
yeah
common law which is living together for
a certain amount of time
so i know a thing or two about
marriage
if i had any advice for you guys it
would be to
make sure your partner is well-fed
watch out for
claws get your shots and uh
patch any holes in the wall that might
give them an opportunity to uh do you
have the license for this attack you
wouldn't be selling
it
louise also mentioned that susan is a
big fan of kanye looking forward to
donda and wanted some
reassurance
regarding waiting for that album how
long can these videos and uh
what i would suggest is to print out the
donda
album cover
and glue it
are you worried about who's working
i kind of agree it's just making me feel
like i wish you were doing this work for
me
i've been begging you for powerpoint for
[ __ ] years and you're basically doing
it for these guys
i'm happy for you guys
regarding the one-year anniversary of
the very first wishes
what do i pay you friggin
i'd have to check
after that five percent
five percent differences
this is
crazy this is a message for susan and
column they better give me five stars
for that [ __ ] that's an ass to
it does make me feel like damn i've been
begging you to make content for so long
and these guys are getting all the good
stuff
like they should be getting the lazy
[ __ ] i should be getting the good [ __ ]
what do i got to buy cameos from you to
get you to work
you just tell me i'll start buying
cameos from you ian that's what it means
yeah i'll buy a [ __ ] cameo from you
on even on the web browser i won't even
use apple wow i appreciate that
and i'll have to stitch it together to
make a powerpoint can you please ian
ethan here can you please make a cameo
about the kanye's new album the first
track thanks and then oh i'm back can
you make a cameo on the second track
i'll do a whole ian album review
you are bullying me
i'll send you my link all right thanks
buddy that's why my cameos aren't as
good because i'm working you know i give
you i give you everything here we go
here we go i'm just gonna hold my tongue
on this one oh yeah this motherfucker's
writing songs
i'll speak for ian too we do it when we
get home don't speak for me yeah yeah
don't go in when we get home we're done
with work after a long wedding you know
what actually you know what people are
calling me snitch [ __ ] these guys i love
you guys but you know what they they
formed a mutiny zach came up to me like
bro let's get on cameo cameo bros i go
out of town and then zach partners up
with ian they're doing collabs they're
making poses
wait dan you're the only
one you have something to say
well are you starting to see why i
didn't want to have a cameo look at the
look at the rip carrying you guys this
is already paused
i still can't load it yeah [ __ ]
a lot of the chat was saying they were
having the same problem so it's not
exclusive to us their website's having
an issue it's flip the shit's flipped i
think we crashed it
yeah you make a really interesting point
a because i would prefer
the cameos be lazy and the effort come
to the show
that's what i would like
okay
to defend myself i always put my best
effort when we're doing the show
okay i noticed you left a little bit
early the other day
[Laughter]
and i will always put pride in the music
because that's another thing i'm
passionate about
i'm mostly jealous of ian's uh tick
tocks you know i just got to say that i
haven't said a single word about abc's
tick tocks he's trying to bury me right
now no no i said the quality of your
tic-tacs are great they did
i said you have the best no me and you
got it yeah yeah yeah actually abe may
have may have opened the flood gate
or time i work every time i work or
cameo i'm because i'm definitely not
yeah
so where do you get off charging 70 for
years ab that's what i don't get
no 70 thing which is a meme i really
i'll always be five dollars
oh it was a meme how many people paid
70.
i'll be okay if you're always five
dollars more than me i'll be okay with
that
if anyone should be raising the price
and if that's the kind of cameos you're
making and you don't want to try you
should be charging like 500 for the
cameo ian and then they actually get a
really good one and you don't have to
deal with a bunch of people buying them
and then if it's not through apple you
can refund it you're putting through if
it's through apple you just straight
refund it you're editing [ __ ] in
premiere i mean how long does that take
you he said for an hour yeah it's like
close to an hour
that's insane no it's fun i like it
you should raise your price though in
i just hate that
i have to bump it up so much
to
for most of it to go to apple
and then the person who wants it is just
paying
apple just tim apple yeah i swear to god
raise it to like 200 and then write if
you buy this through apple i will refund
it
it's funny
i feel like that might get them kicked
off
you'd think so why not i don't know i'm
sure cameo hates apple just as much as
uh i guess probably probably like you
know
right
this is a very interesting landscape i
got to say my mom and dad are also on
cameo funnily enough
my mom is right my mom is popping but my
dad is not
poor gary we never really gave him a
shout out so it's not fair to compare
but my mom is like crushing it dude
let's see what wait the last one she did
was on
hi this is dawn oh she didn't want to
work
we did it
on the side okay okay that's my mom
she's not working she's not an employee
she is the co-host of applause she is
on this channel is she does she how is
she an employee
do you pay her a talent fee she's not on
a salary
no she pulled it out she's like do you
want to do one with me
i don't remember what it was they call
you them the selves
oh the don that's a good one don
and um
thanks for god my mom understands what
cameos are she's just like hey what's up
all right peace
asking to see me on youtube you're
trying too hard yep
see you soon that's it that was it that
was it
but wait this is my thing
i just i wait i wait
and i keep the camera on her oh here
watch this one goes off the rails okay
that's it
oh this is her this is her trailer i'm
sorry
hi this is gone trailer shout out to all
my butterfly they call you them
themselves
oh the don that's a good one
and um
thanks for
asking to see me on cameo trailer
see you soon
ciao
okay that's it
or should i write something
[Laughter]
god god bless your mom he's great so
here let's see what my mom's been up to
this is her most recent one
mary this is donna from families on uh
h3 podcast
your friend uh alicia
sent me something
you're celebrating your 25th birthday
happy birthday
such a beautiful age not that i'm
complaining i'm 65.
i'm happy but 25 was really it was
really a beautiful age
and she tells me that you work at a
i'm out
but my mom is crushing it you know god
bless her i gotta find my dad's because
he was complaining that nobody's buying
his
but i was like why do you need to make
your own i just don't understand why he
was so
oh god shoe next is like he should have
only charged seven dollars bro you don't
want to get on his level
what does that mean after a cut he gets
like three bucks yeah
or apple he probably won i think he
literally does
like thousands he has three thousand
reviews so put that in
yo he gets three bucks though that's
crazy hey let's see what he's up to
i'm gonna see what kind of effort should
i puts in hey everyone shoot
wait
you muted it way to my cameo
either way i've been a legend on the
internet for about 10 years now
and i just love making cameos for anyone
oh this is uh father's day mother's day
yeah we keep getting duped into watching
the trailer do you remember we bought
some from him like a couple years ago
yeah we ride people right everyone shoe
nice again
question
i'm honored
to be able to pick this draft order
for the fantasy football league
now the names were given to me randomly
from iran
hey kenny
shoe nice again
maybe he doesn't know i thought that
he'd be a babysitter
shoe nice again either way
maybe damien might want to go out
sometime
all right chewie keep it up
do you buddy
but if you go to um
bro i'm so fascinated by cameo
i think you're dead
maybe not getting as much traffic
because of his profile picture well we
never plugged him i'll say that but but
let's see gary cline oh this is so bad
wait smash that like button look at his
profile you can't even tell that it's
him dude what are you doing
boomer [ __ ] this is a picture of him
when he was like 20. yeah smash that
like button it's mostly just my sister
and wait so how do i find this
let's see
i want to find the um
they have one for podcasts wasn't there
wait vlog squad bro i gotta hold on
who's in the vlog squad
i don't these people aren't vlogs okay
todd is dirty dom's on every 20 bucks
down bad
let's see what dirty thumbs up to
here this is the most recent one oh my
boy arya it's your boy dirty dom just
here to wish you a new happy birthday
just dying my hair pink i'm officially
losing it i don't know what's going on
anyways my man congrats on turning 19
years old keep killing it keep working
hard stay dirty smoke that dope never go
broke and um
don't let the bed bugs bite i don't know
stay stoney oh that's a good cameo so
little effort
one take no thought
that's cameo
come on guys smash that like button
that's how it's done
oh you've got rudy giuliani raised his
up to 400 holy [ __ ]
there was a time where it was us three
next to rudy and the new and noteworthy
i think there's a screenshot yeah i have
a screenshot
let me see let me see
so funny
oh here's my dad's eye my what do you
think about this hello like
yeah the picture
it looks like
it's just like a little girl and my dad
cut off yeah
what and they're such boomers you can
use your phone to literally just take a
photo
um
you want to watch rudy not he's not
getting a lot of traffic unfortunately
only 15 reviews but let's see what
rudy's up to
hi randy it's uh rudy giuliani and i'm
calling to wish you a very happy
50th birthday which is coming up on the
20th he's plugging his book and
i hope you're properly prepared for it
and you're ready to enjoy it and and uh
understand that 50
is up brody
here's the screenshot this is smelling
through the video this is a totally
unedited
uh
screenshot of the cameo website oh
that's so funny and it's a sexual dance
oh he raised it by 25 huh
new
it's just the fact that it's the crew in
rudy this was on the this was on their
front page of their website
how do you feel about i wonder how they
feel about dirty dom being
in the vlog squad tab
kind of interesting oh good point
so wait i got to find my dad okay so
gary clinton i want to see what he's up
to
i think a lot of the vlogs hot ones are
older because they're unavailable and
like seth is in there too nick's in
there
my dad's about to give a pep talk to
someone hello miranda to my house
recline
working at the office
supposed to be spending time with
theodore you're free my parents come
over to hang out with theodore my dad's
shooting cameos in the backyard this is
just taking over
no respect
hello miranda like he doesn't have
enough free time
better doing these days as father of
ethan
husband of donna
your friend devon thought enough of you
to spend their own hard-earned money to
reach out to me to make this cameo for
you so let's discuss a few things okay
first of all appreciate you really
enjoying the families
horrible angles of the boomers from
super low donna and her monarch she's
doing a great job with that and then for
some reason it's because he's reading
the text you can have an option to leave
the text on screen following porn stars
on twitter
well
obviously i'm going to say that's okay
um
yeah so there's been all kinds of cameo
drama but you know
it's all good baby
um you know and then is there anything
else cameo related uh
let's see
yep that's about it
there you have it
yeah i think ian you really got to raise
your price up that that that wouldn't
make that you know at least be worth
your your time
there i'll think about it
um
well that's about it i mean how long
we've been going
dan's gone couple hours left
i was like what the [ __ ] about two and a
half hours okay perfect they went to go
record some cameos
they're in the bathroom recording cameos
for sure
yeah did you guys do any cameos during
the show
any any phones under the desk that would
be kind of the best
i would honestly not even be mad if one
if abe you did a cameo of me yelling at
you for doing a cameo do it
somebody cough cough it up make it i'm
getting a scam likely should i answer it
sure let's do it
hello
hello
hello
ethan klein this is ethan
my name is ashley fong of the applesauce
republican recall can you hear me okay
what are you on behalf of
stop the republican recall stop in the
recall we're stopping what recall
stopping the republican recall we're
stopping which recall
thank you
oh she don't
i
bro
they didn't even give me a chance
maybe she's just in a hurry she's like i
ain't got time for this [ __ ]
anyway we're about done ela
all right
um
oh thank you cameron
uh cameron gave me a new profile picture
for my dad
here it is this one might work a little
better
[Laughter]
my face instead of my sister as a baby
[Laughter]
anything else you guys want to add we're
wrapping it up
[Music]
ian said you guys were in the bathroom
doing cameos
[Laughter]
dan's got a secret account like well
that was the other wrinkles that dan
didn't want to lower himself
it wasn't it's not about lowering okay
what is it about then
because i just
i don't want to be making content in my
free time i spend you can do it at work
what do you mean
and and do you guys feel that dan is
maybe
is maybe like looking down on you guys
doing you know and that's something i
really appreciate about dan he he sticks
to his own morals but he never judges
anyone else for theirs oh that's not
wrong or that's that yeah no you guys
are pathetic
me making fun of anybody that ordered a
camo for me maybe i'll be down to do
that just promising them like what what
is wrong with you what are you spending
your money on this what are you doing
that's your shtick man i don't know why
you don't see i would love to just roast
people like if you guys have requests
there's a roast like option on there
yeah like i wrote a roast i could do
that all day
i'd be much more comfortable doing it
people are asking if love's on there uh
not that i know of love's on wic and
ethan's feet
dude
i did the math i'd have to sell 50
feet videos to that guy
to make what loves cashing in
speed revenue out now
2.2 2k
i was in gloves
i'm building a game and i just sent you
a script
yeah there's a video yeah i heard you're
you're building a game
i sent you one of the art pieces in
discord if you want to see oh yeah sure
i'd love to
look at us we're funding all these
enterprises we got a super chat saying
vote
oh my god no
no it's not
i'm not
it just happens to look like him okay in
a diaper this is awesome dude
cause he has the
does he have to stop every uh few
minutes to pee in a in a basement uh
so the set the first level is going to
be in a basement in a dark basement
and phase two of the boss will be um the
character the player avoiding p streams
ha ha ha ha i peed in my basement oh so
it is the quartering no no it's now oh
it's not it's not it's just it
everything in this game is fictional and
likeness is mere coincidence oh okay
yeah i'm sorry oh can i tell you guys an
idea okay so you guys know hold on stay
right here i'm super proud of what we're
about to do next
okay i want to kill i want to read this
um
comment go for it
vote no on the california government
recall encourage everyone to vote no or
else california will end up with a
republican
government governor
i'm voting yes on the recall
and i will be voting for angeline
she has my vote
wait you voted angeline yesterday i'm
voting for angeline who is that you
don't know who angelina is talking about
on the show before oh we talked about on
on frenemies actually i just realized
really i'm voting definitely no on the
recall everyone vote no no no no no it's
not that i even love gavin newsom it's
just like it's such
oh my god actually did you guys see uh
there's a candidate uh his name is
chauncey chauncey slim killins
have you seen him i'm considering here
i'm considering voting for him as well
slim killins that's nancy slim killins
for california governor everybody yo you
know what i think it's about time that
we get a dude named chelsea
he just does it different
yep so here's what i'm so here's
something that's [ __ ] that we've been
stewing on
so here's a picture of ryan cavanaugh
kissing harvey weinstein
right
but it's owned by getty
are you showing it or am i just saying
you're
yeah no you're yeah you're showing it
okay
this image is not owned by either of
these men it's owned by getty images
right and so what that means is that we
can buy the license we bought it for the
podcast but we can buy a license for
distributing it on a t-shirt
so to raise money for the lawsuit
we're working now
on a very special idea
limited edition t-shirt of ryan kavanagh
kissing harvey weinstein
on a t-shirt signed by everyone in the
crew
special edition to raise money for the
lawsuit and it will read something like
um
if only ryan cap this i'm just
spitballing i'm not sure what it will
say yet we have to go by the lawyers but
right if only ryan kavanaugh
loved free speech as much as he loves
harvey weinstein
[Laughter]
[Music]
and and and and so we're actually able
to license this image because it's owned
by getty
now i don't expect anyone to actually
wear this shirt but it's a special
edition you're free to wear a shirt the
shirt i know i will on the show
but it will help us fundraise for the
lawsuit and uh make some really cool
merch do you want this for teddy fresh
or can we use it
you can keep it
[Laughter]
yeah
so we're so
we've got saying take my money exactly
it's a really good idea and it's going
to be signed it's going to be special
edition it's going to a good cause it's
just fantastic great idea but i just
love that this is owned by getty
he gave him a nice big kiss on the head
and we love that for him
so that's good that's what we're going
to have to look forward to i just
donated ten dollars said my first super
chat if you put that on a shirt i'm
gonna buy it 100 thank you well at first
at first i got some pushback like who
the [ __ ] would wear that yeah but i'm
like you don't understand it's the
it's a collectible
is there gonna be a limited amount or
yeah yeah yeah
we'll make well the license says we can
make a max of three thousand shirts
oh oh somebody just in chat just said
will it be flipped
we should just mirror the image
oh but i want this what it is
yeah your thing is flipped brian
cavanaugh your thing is flipped
so
i don't think we'll sell five thousand
do you think we can sell five thousand
five pieces
i don't think you said three and i think
five this license says you can sell five
thousand
yeah should we send ryan kavanaugh one
absolutely we should send one to his um
complimentary
and signed by everyone with love we can
send it to the law the lawyers or the pr
people just on you know care of ryan
cavanaugh nice little card you know if
we sell 5 000 of them for like 35 bucks
we're signing 5 000 shirts i don't think
you are you better [ __ ] stop with the
cameo to start signing holy [ __ ]
there's no way we're gonna sell five
thousand we might i don't know i don't
know i mean it's they're only 35 bucks
or we could do like a special edition
hundred shirts and then because i wonder
if it's better to sell like a thousand
of them at like a hundred bucks a piece
because it's like that's that's stupid
that's too much money
35 is kind of i don't know i gotta
crunch the numbers on this now's not the
time but i just want to let you guys
know where our heads at right pretty
exciting
get your signing hands ready boys
[Applause]
but dude that's i mean ryan cavanaugh's
gonna be really happy to see you not
only are we celebrating his commitment
to free speech and his love for harvey
weinstein
um
we're also going to be putting money in
the bank
to uh prepare ourselves for
future losses the legal battle with him
you know so he'll be it's very good
sounds fun
the rainy day fun
it's not a rainy day fun i'm spending
like i'm spending like 20 30 000 a month
on this lawsuit
and you know not complaining the lawyers
are doing great work i'm not complaining
it's just it's expensive
uh
javier just donated 129 i guess pesos
mexican pesos a mexican nobody knows who
they are i'm aware that in public
perfect
really even in mexico they didn't they
didn't hear about it
yeah this is american news
um
i want you know what would be fun is
once we send the shirts out i want to
see people wearing them in public
well and then i don't think you can wear
harvey weinstein in public at least in
america
and that was what i said it's like
there's gonna wear pictures
yeah and then
what's interesting is you're right it is
offensive and ryan cavanaugh's given a
big beautiful kiss on the head
all right
so it is offensive you're right oh my
lord so
let's do a poll i want to know just be
honest i'm i actually just really want
to know how many of these shirts we
should buy
and just be like what what what price
point are we thinking like 35
i would still put also don't make it as
an option because i'm curious you know
okay good who would you say i would buy
it
i would not buy it don't make it
i would buy it
i would
just
yeah there's a good chance he's gonna
sue us for doing this
but i do think that we're legally in the
in the clear on this one so
you know
all right um okay but what's the price
point like because it's a special
edition fundraiser with the signature
maybe 50 bucks do you think that's too
much
no
would you go up maybe
maybe we should make it don't want to
piss anyone off but go ahead
here i want to know what we can do with
this don't don't post it yet dan because
we have the price okay
he already put it okay post it put the
thing up vote baby go
i think you're hired
tell me what you think we should charge
for it i mean if we're everybody's
signature
once in a lifetime that much for cameos
i mean all of our signatures you're
right 50 bucks what's your last name you
guys did a signing like five years ago
six years ago i don't know
well we did fan meetups with like rip
and dip collabs
and stuff but that that's
so everyone's signature on the crew i
mean that is rare
that probably made that may be the only
time in history that happens when you
cover my carpal tunnel
yeah will you stock up on ben yeah
i will
so maybe 100 bucks for sure
the chat's saying shut the [ __ ] up baby
wait oh yeah well hold on guys we're
trying to raise money for our lawsuit
here because let's see we got 40 here
people are saying people say 40 max
everybody's signature yellow are paying
a b to lay on his couch and talk talk to
you through his phone for five seconds
for 50 bucks
and like in like 180p yeah
all right guys 10 bucks 10 bucks 10
bucks
i think 100 is a good price point that's
a real collectible that's everybody's
signature 900 bucks is a ticket people
are saying four nobody
yeah
that's what people are still thinking 35
35 40. i mean this is the majority of
people are saying yeah maybe 45. we're
overestimating the value i would
undervalue it as well if i was actually
trying you know what i mean well no i
don't i'm taking you guys at your word
here
30 i can't do 30 guys come on give me a
break
70 max
70 sounds good to me all right here's
the
here's the results oh [ __ ] there's a lot
of people not interested but there's a
lot interested
it's about anything
when you take the not buy and don't make
it together it's about different percent
oh no but we still
we still overcome
but there's a big difference between
don't make it and i would not buy let's
not clump them together
i mean they're they're both people that
wouldn't buy it yeah but yeah but
they're not offended by it necessarily
well 15 are apparently so i'm making
this [ __ ] shirt
yeah
or maybe we could do a lemonade i think
it needs to have a disclaimer on it this
is not intended to be worn outside or
something
what that's a shirt they can do whatever
they want with it does it have to be a
shirt what if it's no we could put on
anything i'm just using the graphics
maybe we sign a limited amount
how about a bathrobe a bathroom because
that was what harvey used to
wear
a bad idea
no no no no no
i think a shirt is just the cheapest to
produce and listen it's a funny socks
socks
oh with the photo
a shirt where we sign a limited amount
and then the rest the limited being the
ones we sign
and then the other ones sell for 40
bucks so the ones we signed are like
100. oh that's a good idea and then then
we don't sign a trillion things and pour
into the collectibility right so the
regular ones would be 35. special
edition signed by the whole crew 100. i
like that that's a good ass deal for
everyone to sign
the basic ones would have no signature
no signature although that's not a
selling
i doubt it nobody's going to vibe
i'm
i will pretty much listen people just
yeah i mean people want to support our
lawsuit efforts and they might want a
cool shirt off her if you wanted to
me and zach
yeah
so i won't sign just help me i won't
sign it yeah no that sounds horrible you
guys
all right i don't know but this whole
idea really yeah it's so funny um
you don't love it anymore
i don't know
it's just weird
it's harvey weinstein
it's mostly a picture of harvey no but
it says if only ryan kavanagh loved free
speech as much as he loves harvey
weinstein i know but getty images owns
it
take it up with getty
they're the ones licensing it out to me
oh by the way um
someone called them on the phone getty
to ask about the licensing
and he provided the id for the picture
when the person pulled it up on the
phone they were like noticeably
disgusting
because you know
it's just such a weird picture
they're like can we i wanted to
what is this
let you just tell you how [ __ ] up it
is
oh my god
i just love that it's
ryan's gotta be so sad about that being
on getting images
it's so
funny my god holy [ __ ] you guys
we gotta do it i swear to god we have to
do it and we have to send one to ryan oh
my god
that might be
could that be construed as harassment
sending that to him
why
what's happening about it i'm just
sending him a keepsake it's a
collectible
or maybe we could set up outside trailer
headquarters and hand them out free
shirts oh my god
if we
unsigned one oh controller headquarters
is in la i think we found out right
they're here that would be kind of
amazing video where if we make like a
hundred unsigned and go to trailer
headquarters and just pass out shirts
oh they're in it's in new york i think
they have a building in l.a too
they have an la office
but you know what like i would be i
would be willing to go down there and
hand out some free shirts everyone loves
free shirts that'd be so funny oh man
triller where's triller's office it's
flynn says it's in new york
i'll wear a homemade la one listed
is that worth flying to new york
we do it all we're home for christmas
break
you'll wear it to your family yeah
where's my i love this so awkward
i'm gonna have to ask the lawyers if i
can do that
if i can't go to trailer headquarters to
pass out three shares
i mean you're just on the sidewalk yeah
totally yeah
a billboard wait so okay so tr ryan
kavanagh oh we got it cleared we can put
if only ryan kavanaugh loved free
speeches but she loved harvey weinstein
so that's the chairs
oh wait i'm gonna ask the lawyer ryan
cavanaugh is is not actually the ceo of
triller he's ceo of the parent company
right he's the owner he's the majority
owner of trailer oh he is okay yeah and
then he's the ceo of pr proxima media
right yeah he's got his fingers and all
the so i think
yeah proxima media is in but
i think it has to be trailer employees
yo trailer my things flip flying in new
york then really can i go outside a
trailer
hq
and hand out the shirts
i mean if it's on public prop like yeah
if it's in
we can't go on the premises okay i would
never
i would so i might be on public i don't
think i mean why yeah how could it be an
issue to do that you're right i
shouldn't even ask the lawyer
oh man this is so much fun
at least you're making the best out of
the lawsuit people are loving the
billboard idea yeah the billboard is
kind of epic wait what's the idea put
that image on a giant billboard outside
of triller headquarters let me ask if i
can do that no don't ask this one
comment that just says
and then it's a magnet emoji
wait what
somebody commented ethan magnus emoji
it's not just it's just specifically
ryan cavanaugh wants to sue me over
everything yeah apparently he's getting
ready to add another lawsuit for
defamation for some reason
cool
okay
so now we have copyright infringement
tortoise interference because he's
claiming that we are what could possibly
be definition defamation all we've done
is
he said that saying he looks like harvey
weinstein is defamatory oh come on
that's an opinion that's clearly an
opinion yeah in the last lawsuit they
were suggesting that like saying it was
flipped was defamatory this guy is going
to run himself into the poor house just
on frivolous lawsuits like how can he
afford to do this i agree i don't think
he's as rich as
as he uh thinks he is yes he is
well especially if we can sell shirts
and raise money then we're gonna be stay
above water
and we can fight for fair use all day
long you know what i mean
so wait i'll look into the billboard and
the uh get free shirt giveaways maybe we
could do a bit where we just go to like
times square
or hollywood boulevard and just give out
free shirts and get people's reaction
all right
it's got a
sort of a non-sequitur but
uh super chat for twenty dollars please
use the intro music from the theo vaughn
interview episode 109 as today's outro
did we use like special music no no no
no no no i i think i know what this is
referring to
uh
check the disc
by the way uh unrelated ela i wanted to
show you this
what reality show was this guy from i
know we watched it
who is this guy we watched a reality
show with him
um
i can't really see him
you'll see his face you don't you
recognize him
kind of yeah god what was he on i don't
remember is it not like bachelor or
something imagine all right no all right
no
well anyway it's so funny he goes
he goes one year ago sleeping on the
floor and here he is throwing money one
dollar bills in a pool in a swimming
pool while nobody pays attention
it's just floating in the water weirdest
flex video ever
nobody's paying attention to them
they're not even picking up the money in
the freaking pool who throws money in a
swimming pool and they're ones too
she's throwing like 20 bucks in the pool
oh they're saying too hot to handle oh
too hot to handle thank you guys
yeah i just thought this was hilarious
he's just like dude i don't think
anyone's watching bro
what the hell are you guys talking about
we do need to go by the way what's this
theo bond stuff you guys are talking
about
yeah i don't know i'll wrap it up we
haven't figured it out well he just
pulled up the episode they're talking
about was listening to intro is it not
the normal podcast music i guess they're
just trying to say use the old music
yeah it's a normal
normal song we don't have that i'm
afraid so we had a lot of fun here this
was fun this is a great time nice to be
back
and uh well it's the weekend baby [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
have a great weekend take care of
yourselves be good stay gold and we'll
see you next week we'll be back to our
oh this weekend we're uploading families
yes that's right
[Applause]
or fun
you said in the announcement sunday so
let's just do it on sunday
yeah
[Music]
shredder was